last night was absolutely crazy Elon
Musk files his lawsuit against Media
Matters an organization that seeks to
Simply lie about and Destroy people's
private businesses because they disagree
politically and then truth social file
the lawsuit against 20 different media
outlets for a coordinated defamation
scheme where all of these Outlets
falsely claimed that truth social lost
$73 million now the crazy thing is
apparently they're all citing an SEC
filing that never says this so it's
going to get really really interesting
but here's where it gets interesting
even more so this morning when I wake up
and I say okay let's take a look at
where we're at with this Elon Musk story
there's a new story it's weird it's
actually an old story from about a month
and a half ago about a man who is suing
Elon Musk a Jewish man strangely when
you Google search Elon Musk now the news
you get is not that he's suing Media
Matters it is not the story explaining
how X and Elon Musk claim Media Matters
defrauded people it's actually a story
uh from a month and a half ago about
Elon mus being sued by a Jewish man for
being anti-semitic now why would all of
these different news outlets run an old
story at the exact same time my friends
it would seem that the war for the
internet is on and uh it's going to get
particularly crazy moving forward but
there's a lot happening behind the
scenes we'll talk about this we've got a
bunch of stories about actors
celebrities actresses is getting fired
over their statements about Israel and
Palestine so cancel cultures uh cancel
culture is coming for them too we'll
talk about all that but before we get
start of my friends head over to cast
brew.com to buy the best cup of coffee
you've ever had the rise with Roberto Jr
Halloween Limited Edition zombie blend
is still up and once it's gone it's gone
for good but of course you can get the
Appalachian Knights and rise with
robberto JR the two favorites when you
buy Cas Brew Coffee not only are you
getting the best cup of coffee you'll
ever have you're actually helping us
support our Endeavor to build physical
locations where people can get together
and hang out and share ideas and I think
that uh it's going to be really
important in winning the culture War so
that's what we do it we got whole bean
we got ground we got kcups casper.com
but also head over to timcast.net
no longer exists that's right
SNR has now officially launched
scanner.com and uh that's where you will
find all of the great work from our
journalists field reporting now exists
atr.com we are going to be doing really
really great things over there as well
so I'm super excited for that so smash
the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and a whole lot more we got the Harmon
Brothers of Angel Studios do you guys
want to introduce yourselves Neil Harmon
co-founder and CEO of angels Studios
glad to be here Tim well thanks for
thanks for coming in Jeff Harmon
co-founder and chief content officer and
we're excited to be here and you guys
did of course you were you were behind
sound of Freedom which was a massive
success and uh uh what was you had a
documentary that just came out recently
which after death after death and now
you have the shift coming out uh what in
like a week week December one it looks
really good I'm really excited for it we
have a we have a clip and uh it's great
yeah I don't want to I don't want to say
too much I'd rather just play it later
but uh it's looking awesome man you guys
are you guys are killing it and I'm glad
to see look as we're talking about Elon
Musk fighting this big battle all of
these stories are stories of us storming
the battlefield taking the field taking
the center stage and winning these are
all tremendous victories so it's super
exciting to hear this will be a lot of
fun talking to you guys about this and
uh so thanks for hanging out we got
Hannah clir hanging out hi I'm Hannah
Clair rmo I was a writer at timcast news
but now I'm a writer at scanner and
Ian's here hi everyone Ian cross and Tim
I love you man and I I really appreciate
your attention to detail because picking
up on this Elon Musk the the multiple
Outlets running this weird muddying the
waters thing I don't know that a lot of
humans would pick up those kind of
patterns so I really appreciate your
brain man thanks for well I mean it's
like you Google search the story to you
want to cross reference the different
stories and check their sources and you
don't find it you find a different story
We we'll talk about we'll talk about it
we got we got search hang out yes I'm
here surge.com U ready whenever you are
to I do want to make one quick mention
if if you go to the cast Brew Coffee
account on Twitter SLX we got a Black
Friday code it's BL KF R i23 and you can
get uh buy one get one with a bunch of
different uh uh Blends and uh bunch of
different types of coffee that we got so
pick that up this week and I'm going
just want to mention Thursday and Friday
we are not here why because we're doing
what everyone should be doing hanging
out with our families so uh tomorrow
will be the last show of the week but
that being said we can now just jump
into the the big news here big news
there's Angel Studios right there let's
let's let's get to it we have this from
wired Elon musk's Media Matters lawsuit
will have a chilling effect musk has
filed his thermonuclear suit against
Media Matters for America at the same
time the Texas AG launched an
investigation into the nonprofit now
this we saw yesterday of course there's
a bunch of updates today it's slowly
moving I think the the fact that the AG
is going for criminal charges against
these organizations is particularly
interesting but here's what was
interesting this morning and this is
something I don't see a lot of people
writing up just yet but it's something
that must be covered Google search Elon
Musk and click news and what do you get
well what's the biggest Story I mean
this is a massive lawsuit you've got a
massive boycott X is being slammed by
Major advertisers the tune of tens of
millions of dollars but you know that's
that story Falls to uh uh Second Stage
the top story right now is far-right
conspiracy theorists accused 22-year-old
Jewish man of being a Neo-Nazi then Elon
Musk got involved aspiring lawyer sues
Elon Musk Jewish student sues Elon Musk
all of a sudden all of these different
Outlets a bunch of different Outlets
start running a story instead that Elon
Musk is being sued for uh this is the
crazy thing about this story let me let
me let me show you this CNN runs uh runs
this this is last night at 10:12 p.m. it
was it was it was updated that's that's
a couple hours after he launches the
story now news that this dude was suing
Elon Musk is from I believe mid October
early October here's what they write Ben
Brody says his life was going fine he
had just finished College stayed out of
trouble and was prepping for law school
then seemingly out of nowhere Elon Musk
uses his considerable social media clout
to amplify an online mob's misguided
rant accusing the 22-year-old from
California of being an undercover agent
in a Neo-Nazi group that's completely
false that's actually very very false
Elon Musk replied to someone vaguely
referencing a guy who was in college and
wanted to work for the government and no
one accused the the the the individual
of being an undercover agent in a
Neo-Nazi group they accused these people
all of them of being undercover agents
period in a fake Nazi group now whatever
what I can say is Define coordinated I
suppose when a bunch of media outs all
run this story and it shoves down the
big news and covers it up it's kind of
like uh every time what was the thing
that was happening every time Hunter
Biden you know was was caught doing
something aliens were proven to exist
yeah I mean just this week they they an
example of this is like he launches the
rocket the the the spa Starship he gets
up the largest spacecraft in history
makes the separation successfully and
gets into space and I try to look up the
news and it's all like Elon mus fails
with rocket because it blows up or you
know lies yeah it's just it's just
straight up faults it's one of the most
successful moments in history so and
there and and all the headlines are his
he failed they're all lies this was uh
the first launch uh it wasn't the first
launch uh SpaceX launched something a
year ago or whatever yeah all the media
reports shocking failure media rocket
explodes SpaceX intentionally blew it up
they they were doing the launch to
collect data uh so SpaceX launches
Starship they did the exact same thing
they launched it to collect data because
they have to build a rocket how do you
do it well you have to build prototypes
try them see where they fail collect the
dat and then the safety measure is you
blow up you blow him up and the media
reports that he's a failure it's not
working this is crazy and then at the
same time this whole entire anti-semitic
thing comes out or they're covering his
custody battle with Grimes a lot right
now try pain him as yeah it's just like
terrible moral person the last time you
had us here it was a Fabian Martin's
story about sound of Freedom that the
financier they of sound of Freedom was a
sex trafficker and it was a guy who is
totally exonerated later on but he was
all over the press and his face was
everywhere and they were trying to take
that film down it was also like one of
100,000 investors I believe wasn't it
yeah he's one of thousands of
investors 50 bucks he gets accused of an
accessory to
kidnapping and it the and then it got
the judge was like I don't know how
you're an accessory to kidnapping
because there's no even charge for
kidnapping but somebody went into the
theater screenshotted all the investor
names cuz that's the only place you can
get
then digitized them wow then cross check
them across all the local criminal
databases to find one guy who had been
accused of a kidnapping and then the
headline is finance year $50 investor of
thousands of sound of Freedom arrested
for kidnapping children M I'm in London
I have my angel shirt on I'm at this TSA
security in London I don't know what
they call it there and one of the
security guys comes up and says oh I
have tickets to your movie and he's like
are you the producer and I was like oh
no I I'm not the producer I'm a
distributor he's like oh good because
the producer apparently is like a
kidnapping
kids well now they're going they're
going after uh Tim Ballard with all
these stories which sound completely
insane but I got to tell you man but you
get like what What's Happening Here is
very common so what did you do
personally and what do you advise people
to do when the media does run stuff like
that there was a a really wise um the
one of the executive producers on the
one of the films was coming up he's in
his
90s very successful businessman and he
just called and said guys when the when
everybody's shooting at you get in the
Foxhole or else you'll get
shot well there you go so don't make
noise basically stay just stay calm and
keep I I I don't know though I don't
know though you look how the me look
what the media does they they say uh the
best defense is a good offense when Elon
Musk goes after Media Matters and is
exposed in what I believe expands the
government collusion narrative in the
censorship industrial complex we've got
the releases from the Republican party
we know about the releases from the
Twitter files now Elon Musk is going
after Media Matters and they're saying
they have data hard proof that Media
Matters fabricated the claims against
them to try and get advertisers to pull
out what does the media do immediately
launch a totally different story to
attack Elon Musk to drown it out y so
I'm I'm kind of wondering if perhaps in
in you know World War I sty trench
combat you're getting shot at you get
down that's a good point but perhaps in
the world of PR and media what Elon Musk
needs to do is layer on another story
immediately now the issue of course is
will the Press even cover it or will
they let the Search terms be accurate
right and and and here's the thing I I
think it's probably Google look why are
people writing in this story I think
it's very weird that CNN chose to write
a month and a half old story and just
publish it right now with vague and
misleading language what do we call that
we call that Mal information it's it's
technically the truth but it's not
actually what's going on and then other
outlets pick it up because this is what
they do Google knows put this on top so
when it appears at the top of Google
when you search for Elon Musk I think
it's a big Tech play and I think big
Tech is colluding with the government
because we've already seen hard proof
they've been doing it or and or that the
advertisers are coordinating and they
all advertise on alphabet and on
whatever companies are posting this CNN
and all these people are getting that
same ad money that pulled out of Twitter
and they're they're working I don't know
if they're just bystanders in this or if
they're complicit I think it's difficult
for people as an individual to to combat
U the tech Giants and especially anyone
controlling a search engine if they if
if they want to I mean I'm I'm going to
reference Taylor Swift I know you guys
were all waiting for it but when she
started dating tra Travis Kelce she went
to a New York Jets game before that when
you Google Taylor Swift Jet it talked
about all these articles from two years
before talking about her carbon
footprint and how bad it was and people
thought she has engineered this
relationship to get to this game so it
completely changes what shows up when
you Google these terms I mean the the
challenge here is that Elon Musk is now
up against the people who want CNN's
article to be at the front so even if he
were able to get some big headline he
had sympathetic out sympathetic
journalist take on his story cover it
accurately it doesn't mean that the
search torm that the the way the
algorithms work out will be evenly
applied to him do you get what I'm
saying I think I like your metaphor
about get down Duck and Cover when the
fire when the incoming enemy fire is
happening and this is like when people
are writing crappy articles about you
like don't make noise cuz you're going
to look guilty but that's important why
you have allies to fire on the position
that's attacking your Foxhole to lighten
the fire so you cross that's right and
that's our job essentially right now is
what we're doing is we're we're exposing
this weird algorithm these people are
evil that's it I mean Twitter and
Facebook running back doors allowing the
government to come in and and basically
get content removed it's
unconstitutional deep corruption deep
corruption it's it's is it is pure
corruption and it is it is over evil
these people are doing it for personal
gain that's just it man we were talking
about free speech I had interviewed
Josie the redheaded libertarian today on
my YouTube channel we were talking about
free speech and how like the ability for
a private company just to shut off a
bunch of people's ability to communicate
or the way certain aspects of my
communication with you might not show up
like that's we wrote a constitution and
fought a revolution to avoid that from
happening we had the king pressing down
on our necks collectively and
disallowing us from speaking out in
public no more never again that was the
point but this also happens with
companies that control Banks right I
mean PayPal can say I don't like what
you're talking about online you can no
longer use our service which makes it
actually difficult to do a lot of
business interfacing this is true of
MailChimp this is true of a ton of
different companies that decide we don't
want to be associated with you because
we have a vague term to the next level
is when it's transactions that is the
next level like that's the deeper level
below free speech that's the foundation
if you can't if you don't have the
freedom to
transact then you're like what what can
you do
it's like the truckers in Canada they
just they just shut them down I just
think we're winning across the board in
every way I mean we got a super chat a
moment ago and they were like how could
how could the Democrats even put someone
else on the primary ballot because it's
too late in several States Biden can't
win the dude's completely out of his
mind he's losing support among the the
Hollywood Elites Michael rapor says he's
going to vote for Trump or he's
considering voting for Trump I mean this
is crazy Elon Musk filing the law suit
everybody's going on on off offense and
I can tell you this too ladies and
gentlemen I can't say too much cuz in
ter in legal uh issues you know you got
to keep things pretty quiet until you
make your moves but there is so much
more happening behind the scenes let's
just I'll just put it this way many
phone calls many phone calls have been
happening and there's a lot of prominent
individuals who are Like This Is War
there was a post recently where someone
suggested that any prominent influencer
on Twitter should should file an amicus
brief or join the lawsuit Elon Musk is
filing because guess what everybody you
know that money you were making on
Twitter oh wow it's gone it's all gone
so when I was getting two to 3,000 bucks
every two weeks maybe about five grand a
month gone so medium matters did not
just smear and defame Elon musk's
platform but stripping revenue from
everybody through fraudulent means yeah
so there's a lot and there's a lot more
than that so uh yeah Media Matters is
the worst we're still spending a lot
with X how's it been how's the
engagement been well it's great this is
interesting with sound of Freedom was
the first time that and this is within
months after a very short time after
Elon acquired Twitter is that our our
main investors uh Giga fund that's
invested in SpaceX invested in a whole
bunch of Elon companies um they they
they called us and they were like hey
how can we improve the system so they're
they're working very hard to improve the
Twitter advertising system and it's
working like Twitter has not com had a
competitive leg that even comes close to
competing with Facebook for targeted ads
and direct response ever and now they're
starting to compete like advertisers
need to be aware it's worth taking time
to invest in Twitter now part of the
reason why sound of Freedom was
successful was because Twitter figured
out how to make ads work and they're
getting better and they're getting
better and better and so I I think that
this Twitter just has to survive the dip
and then they'll climb back back out of
it because they're actually innovating
they're actually making changes and
they're listening to the audience and
the customers and so uh for us we spend
where it works and I I I think that um
if we can do I mean we're known Haron
Brothers known for doing poopery Squatty
Potty purple mattress Lumi deodorant
these billion dooll cpg companies and
mattress companies and and um and these
like this I can tell you Twitter is
starting to figure it out we're going to
be doing a big ad ad push in the
beginning of next year we we're we're
already doing uh big ads for infringed
our latest documentary by Lauren
Southern and johnis and uh when they
announced they were pulling out it was
Seth Dylan who started the Cascade
saying we're to commit 250k I said I'm
on board and uh it's just the easiest
marketing play in the world join in the
fun Everybody by announcing we're doing
an adby we get 10 times the Press from
our from the adby so like let me just
stress I want to buy ads on X we did we
were already buying ads we we we we
created a $50,000 budget for infringed
and launch that campaign and I we we are
having some issues so I need someone
from Twitter's help but uh we can I can
we can make some connections yeah that'd
be great because like I don't know I I
something weirds happening in the
backround but I digress so uh when this
this when when Seth Dylan's like Hey
we're going to do this thing I was like
well we're already advertising on X we
already want to want to do more let me
just announce that I too will be doing
this enjoining their efforts exactly and
then I get articles written about me so
standing up for what I believe in
results in 10 times the Press we would
have gotten just off the ad campaign
alone the Tweet announcing the ad
campaign got 7,000 retweets so it's just
the marketing rights itself let's you
know you know this idea I had a long
time ago marketing should do something
good was was you know it reminds me of
that movie um Hancock where Jason
Batman's character is like everyone puts
the heart on their brand I'm like well
that's kind of dumb my idea was
companies should compete with how much
they can accomplish ideologically in in
alignment with their values so uh you
know for instance instead of spending
$50 million doing this Nationwide
campaign where you hire a celebrity to
throw a football you spend $50 million
investing in Road schools or you know
veterans like helping veterans or
nonprofits and then instead of doing
this big commercial where celebrity
throws a football you just do a
commercial where it's a guy standing in
front of like a a VA saying instead of
spending $50 million on throwing of
football we just gave it to wounded
veterans to help those those and I'm
like that's the kind of marketing we
should be doing competing with each
other to do the most good so I'm like if
I can buy ads to promote Tim cast.com
and the projects we're doing and it has
the added benefit of winning the culture
War man I'll spend all my money let's
just let's roll get done Mr Beast he'll
actually take cameras in and show the
people crying with joy from tasting
fresh water for the first time in their
lives and things and you may argue it's
exploiting the people that are getting
the video taken of them but he's giving
away Wells and they attacked him for it
the media came after him well he's an
oppressive figure trying to help people
crazy guarantee he's he's anything but
and you should watch his video where he
brings 100 Wells to people that are
starving of fresh water essentially
dying you know having distended stomachs
and these little kids these this fly is
driving me nuts are you guys watching
it's attacking everybody anyone that
starts to talk it's like I feel hostile
work en go straight to the speaker holy
crap I just swatted and didn't squeeze I
had like some some sympathy for open the
door and cross our fingers he leaves
yeah I'll do that there you go yeah the
F's attacking everybody fun while lasted
fly well he's gone off what were you
saying Ian before awesome thing oh about
Mr Beast uh he was just showing video of
these kids and I mean if you've ever
spent time with kids in like um in a
impoverish impoverished nation and you
see them the kids that drink poop water
basically the same river water that they
drink out of they poop into it's sad
because their stomachs are fat and
Bloated I saw it in South America when I
was in Peru and it was there's so happy
people CU they don't know they didn't
know but once they found out they
wereing livid and and it's just to be
able to to help people children
especially I want I want to jump to the
story before we get into uh movie stuff
we got this from the Hollywood report we
got a couple stories actually Melissa
Barrera dropped from Scream seven after
social media posts amid Israel Hamas War
this is this is really funny she led
both 2022 scream and the sixth
installment released earlier this year
and uh she basically said it's genocide
it's ethnic cleansing Gaza is currently
being treated like a a concentration
camp spy glass the company behind uh the
scream franchise had no comments and uh
they gave her the boot we also got this
from sr.com Susan Sarandon dropped by
talent agency for anti-semitic comment
she was get she's getting roasted
heavily after she was at a rally and she
made a bunch of comments Pro Palestinian
rally and then uh I think we have
another one here this one's not as as as
as important as the Hollywood
celebrities United Airline Pilot removed
from service over Pro Hamas posts so
keeping it you know I wanted to
highlight that in terms of the cancel
culture I don't agree with these people
being fired for having bad opinions I
also don't care I'm not going to come to
their defense and I'm just going to
laugh as the as the door hits their ass
on the way out because too many of these
people absolutely are anti-free speech
too many of these people in New York
these far-left groups have been waging a
war on Free Speech but that being said I
do think we should be careful and maybe
this Melissa Barrera I don't know what
she's all about maybe she believes in
free speech so I'm going to I'm going to
look into them and if they're in favor
of free speech I'll defend their free
speech if not sorry but what we're
seeing is look the Old Guard is is in is
in freef Fall yeah Hollywood the actors
they're they're split where their talent
are ideologically at odds with their
institutions and I'm not going to sit
here and tell you who's right or who's
wrong we we can have a Palestine Israel
discussion later I'm just pointing out
they're starting to fire people the
industry is not doing so well in the
meantime time seems like Independent
Media is is is is just skyrocketing I
mean a few years ago if I would have
talked about the sound of Freedom people
would not have believed me if I would
have said there's going to be a new
studio they're going to launch a movie
it's going to defy all expectations
crack into the top of the box office 100
what is that $200 million 250 $250
million people would be like what dude
you can't beat Hollywood and now
Hollywood's dying I mean billion dollar
loss for Disney how you guys doing sound
of Freedom still in theaters it is the
world it is throughout the world but in
the US we just had the last day in the
theaters it was last Friday or Thursday
yeah anyway it went for like 127 days in
the US theaters it's on my uh it's on
Amazon yes when new releases it's like
the second one right there yeah it was
the in the top 25 most pre-ordered
movies of all time on Apple it's amazing
I mean it is you can really see a shift
in uh focus and groups that once had a
very tight com camaraderie are now
splitting apart there's this poll from
Gallup that came out I think today
saying that Biden has lost 11 points in
support in one month among Democrats
among people who would theoretically be
completely behind him so if you can see
it shifting in the political discourse
it's obviously happening in the cultural
discourse there's going to be Fallout
from the fact that people looking each
other and say I won't I won't even talk
to you I won't work with you I cannot be
around you if you express these opinions
that's crazy I think the kids people
that just see things for what they are
are like
the the um diversity for the sake of
diversity it was tried in like 2021
pretty pretty heavily and then it it was
obvious that like if you're not casting
the best person regardless of what they
look like you're you're not making the
best movie I mean looks are somewhat
important but I think Talent you see it
in the eyeballs yeah the best person for
the character whatever that means so and
now becoming obvious and it's showing in
the budgets like Disney just launched
the worst Marvel movie of all time
financially and they did really po
before that like let's let's let's think
about this it's a good point the Marvel
right it's the MCU it's got It's got
three female leads and a female villain
lead that what what was their budget
$300 million I think and it hits the it
hits the opening week with 46.1 million
the lowest box office of all time now I
assume it'll make some money somehow but
I kind of feel like this one's dead in
the water it is crazy to see the
Behemoth of the MCU decide to get woke
and then go broke well they uh was it
the the reviewer um the drunk reviewer
what's his name
drinking I hope his name just the drunk
R that's way better Australian dude what
yeah yeah the drunken a SE movie yeah I
know who you're talking about he's a
reviewer I know who I'm talk sorry I I
it doesn't matter what figure it out he
he was saying that M that Disney was
required by contract to make critical
Drinker yeah critical yeah critical
drink required by contract to make this
movie yeah that they they didn't have a
choice when they they they signed an
agreement to make this movie a long time
ago and they tried to wiggle out and
they tried to get out and they were
forced basically through their contracts
to finish it out and he's like and it
shows there's no passion they oh it's
the shortest movie they've done they
people are mentioning that it really
looked like they were just trying to get
rid of it yeah because they had to they
had to make it they signed the
agreements a long time you know what I
think happened I think uh early uh this
is maybe like eight years ago man it's
been that long like when they were doing
Avengers Infinity War they needed to get
Brie Larson in it because they were like
Captain Marvel will be the new Iron Man
yeah and so she signed a deal for so
many films and then she appears in a
bunch of commercials everyone despises
her she's snoody she's mean she goes on
social media and she posts really awful
nasty stuff and then they're just like
we need to get rid of her and she's cost
them so much money here's the funny
thing cancel culture right they're
firing these actors and actresses and
you know why they're doing it because
they're like we are going to lose so
much money because this woman went on
Twitter and started calling Israel
genocides and all this stuff again not
here to make an argument about Israel
Palestine they're they're they're
looking at how much money they're going
to lose because of it and I get it and
that's that's that's that's a tough
that's a tough issue but understand
this it was uh uh just the other day
when we had Danny polishchuk on he made
the excellent joke of as soon as Elon
Musk bought Twitter everybody just went
there are two genders
but but hold on like it's funny because
if you really think about it isn't it
absolutely insane that before Elon
acquired Twitter if you said men are not
women you would get banned no question
Megan Murphy she's a writer and an
activist she tweeted men aren't women
though she didn't insult anybody they
banned her per for four years she was
banned until finally I think it was
because of yan mus gets brought back we
actually lived in that world where you
could not go on a major social media
platform and say boys are boys and girls
are girls but now where are we what what
was happening back then is companies
were genuinely terrified Dave Ruben I
don't think sound of Freedom would have
been as successful as I don't think it
would have hit terminal uh sorry escape
velocity without Twitter they would they
would have suspended you guys in two
seconds they would made up Aon we could
we could have brute forced ourselves
maybe to 80 million just through
marketing but the amount that it takes
to get up to 250 million require requ
Ires you to hit escape velocity and
without Twitter Twitter was the only
social platform where we were trending
number one after it launched over and
over and over again all the rest of them
is just not there did you have a plan
for Twitter when you were launching like
did you go in knowing that Twitter was
going to be a resource we we actually
that is why we got into advertising on
Twitter is because now Elon owned
Twitter and we were like we can actually
trust they're not going
to uh mess with mess with this we could
see when we uh were a iing the sound of
Freedom trailer because because of our
advertising career like the number for
for the views and the number of shares
that the videos got and the amount of
activity it just didn't match like
nobody would comment nobody would like
but they were being shared like crazy so
you you you you post your video people
re-sharing it like extremely high rate
super viral trailer on Facebook the
second generation shares have no
comments you can just go through they're
fake so the first one no no they're
sharing everybody's sharing it but
they're sharing it into the void right
right they think I'm just sharing the
video I'm excited I shared it and then
no one sees it right no one comments on
it and so the the reshares the second
generation is where the trick happens on
these other social platforms is you you
you you post it and a whole bunch of
people reshare it and you go oh my video
is doing really well but then you go dig
into the reshares and they're not
getting comments they're not getting any
engagement die I think that Facebook
should alter their advertising scheme so
that if you share an advertise post it's
still going to get advertising pressure
on your reshare yes I agree with that
yeah reshare should should be promoted
so with uh with
X I think I think uh let me go back in
time actually uh I knew these guys that
were investigating advertising systems
on so on on big tech companies and they
were saying at least half of all of the
buys you you purchases are fake when you
when you say I'm going to put $1,000 in
ads towards this video and then you get
let's say you know 100,000 views 50,000
are fake fabricated and so what Elon
Musk is just Bots they're just Bots yeah
and so this is great for the makes sense
with the performance before exactly but
here's what happens because it was awful
performance you couldn't it was like
brand marketing on Twitter that's the
only way to do it but then elanos
changes everything and he says you have
to it's all ads are only going to appear
on verified accounts only count against
verified user views smartest thing and
no one really talks about it it's
working what exactly what Elon Musk is
was saying to the advertisers is listen
if you spend $100,000 on that platform
how do you know you're getting real
people with us on Twitter users only get
ads ads only display against verified
accounts so smart and so the money is
only the money is only spent if verified
individuals with check marks see the ad
so now when you when you when you spend
a th000 bucks and you get 10,000 views
oh it's so much less so what it's real
people you'll see your conversions go up
yep that's huge I wanted to kind of talk
a little bit more about Disney and and
about how the problems that they've been
having um the uh we were saying that
people are being fired from from movies
or I don't know if those Disney movies
but because of their talks about Hamas
or Israel or whatever I'm also concerned
that big production companies um
Paramount I don't know call them out by
name if it even matters but that they
have large institutional in
I don't know if you guys do too I know
that angels are like 100,000 people that
all fund the pro program mixture it's a
mixture a mixture okay because if Crow
and institutional if one big
institutional guy is like listen I my
family's in Israel and I want only
pro-israel movies and propaganda out
there right now and full stop then
they're going to pull all their money
from a company that's trying to make a
movie with an actor that's crapping on
Israel potentially and so these
investors are deciding the creative flow
of the movie industry in that sense or
of that industry and that's a fail man
if you can't be as creative as you want
with your best actors and your craziest
ideas good luck how can you compete with
people that are doing that so how do you
guys work with the institutional to not
get co-opted by the institutional
Investments so the only way to get
through Angel is through the angel Guild
so that those 100,000 people Jeff is the
chief content officer he can't if he had
if he loved your show Ian that you were
you were sharing with us he can't take
it there unless the angel Guild sees it
first and they are like the you know
they they can see
whether something has a problem that's
what the wisdom of crowds is is that
yeah sound of Freedom sound of Freedom
was watched by 30 plus million people
worldwide in theaters because a thousand
Guild members Angel Guild members voted
for that show yep wow so like if a movie
got made with an actor that was making
these comments about Hamas or something
and then but the angel invest or if the
guild was like we still love it put it
through there's some descent are there
investors that once it gets through
they're like I'm not going to put money
on that one is that part of the process
they have a choice they have a choice
whether they want to invest in a project
for sure yeah it doesn't it doesn't
guarantee that we'll be able to get the
film uh to do a partnership with the
film like there's still a lot of things
that happen have to happen after the
guild but we cannot take a film into
Angel Studios until it passes The Guild
and they so there's 100,000 people
they've invested in different projects
they can they go on they they they they
become members of The Guild and then you
get to as a member of The Guild you get
to vote on the stuff that goes to
theaters vote on the stuff that goes on
the platform and if you don't pass it it
doesn't come on Angel and is that the
threshold a thousand people you said a
thousand people a thousand is like tell
statistical significance yeah
statistical significance of the audience
yeah and so you'll have you know a few
hundred to a thousand people watching
each movie there's 21 movies submitted a
week right now to Angel Studios on
average 21 movies a week There's 100
plus thousand people going through these
movies voting then they decide what
comes in and then as a guild member when
you become a member of The Guild it's
like an Amazon Prime membership or
Costco membership you get perks like you
get complimentary tickets to every
single movie because you're an angel
executive like oh I was going to say I
like this I like this idea you know
Ian's concern is one guy can be like I'm
shutting your movie down because I don't
like what that person said that's
possible and exactly I may disagree with
these these these you know people
cheering Hamas for being critical of
Israel to varing degrees uh but I do
think they have a right to speak their
mind and it is shocking when a studio
says they're going to shut them down so
I like the idea that with you guys one
person can't just do it it has to be a
community effort so think about this way
if you get a m a lead actor in a film
and then he comes out you know to do
press for it and says a whole bunch of
nasty awful like really shockingly
offensive stuff and then the community
says we don't want to go forward with
this project that that would end the
project that would that's what I think
that's the way to do it I'll tell you
why not all speech is socially
acceptable if there was a guy who went
out and started demanding that schools
start giving these books to kids I'm
pretty sure a lot of people will be like
no no no no no no no no like this is not
someone we want to support right that
crosses a line for for something we
don't want by all means he can go do his
own thing but we're not going to
Greenline it however it's not one guy
it's a large community that has to come
to a a statistically significant
decision amongst themselves is there
ever is there a cap on individual
investors so that one guy can't come in
with 100 million and be like I want yeah
so the last investment I think the cap
was 10 or is it is it 15 last time don't
know $15,000 I don't remember last one
that's very small 15,000 I thought you
going to say 15
million the the cap now the film was
made with bigger investors but once it
passed the guild and then it took on PNA
money which is the way it did the crowd
money PNA it's called it's prints and
advertising so back in the day when you
prints meant you print out a reel of
film and ship it to every single theater
so that they can play it on their
projectors prints and then you print out
the the movie posters those were the
prints that cost a lot of money just to
get those out to the world and then
advertising is how you promote and make
awareness around the film So currently
like prints are like a lot of them are
done over satellite and a lot of them
are done little hard drives you still
mail the hard drives yeah to a lot of
them is that just Old Guard like not
figuring out they can email it yet or
yeah yeah they don't have great internet
maybe or their projectors aren't
connected to these are multi-terabyte
movies these are multi-terabyte movies
you you have to have really good
internet in order to to uh to bring down
that level of a film so prins and
advertising are the prints are the
printing out the posters and that stuff
and then advertising and the the the
crowd invests in prints and advertising
they did it for sound of Freedom they
put $5 million to get sound of Freedom
out to the theaters they put it into
after death they put it into his only
son they put it in the shift which is
coming out on December 1st and there's
thousands of people helping these movies
get off the ground and they become Angel
Investors and then once you become an
angel investor you become part of the
guild and you get a vote on the next
content that comes in and you're part of
the the new gate the the you're
replacing the gatekeeper model the old
gatekeeper model and you're right Ian uh
no go the uh in the traditional system
one Studio would cut the check for PNA
and they get a decide and in this one
we want as many checks as possible
because all those people they're part of
the the audience they want to they want
to be part of shaping the culture
they're going to B drag all their
friends out to the movie yeah all their
relatives everybody they can get I think
an important distinction you know uh in
the idea of cancel culture cancel
culture was basically they would dig
into your past find something you said
10 years ago that either is no longer uh
culturally relevant or now is considered
unacceptable and use that to destroy
your life or in the most egregious most
egregious example this race car driver's
dad dropped a racial slur in the 80s
before he was born so a sponsor dropped
him because of it I'm like that's insane
but let's be real you know we had that
woman on culture war and she said I was
Pro censorship because I said I don't
want these these these adult books in in
grade schools and I'm like yes next
question no question whatsoever it it
it's it's it's not this idea that we
think everyone should be able to say
literally anything in our private spaces
or in our industry that we have to
invest in it freedom is speech means you
can live your life without government
interference and opposing cancel culture
first and foremost has to do with our
moral basic lines right so what happens
is the woke left comes out and says oh
we we've hereby decided that this thing
is no longer acceptable socially and
you're going to lose your job because of
it or a or talking with this person is
no longer socially acceptable and we're
like dude dude dude what are you doing
firing this person over this stuff these
people are saying things that aren't
even that offensive men aren't women
though and Megan Murphy gets banned from
Twitter for that that's it's ridiculous
now if someone went on Twitter and
literally was advocating for violence or
Terror or genocide then we might be like
well okay well now we're getting into
dangerous territory as for like the
calls for extreme violence we've
actually had a great conversation on
this show about the limits of it if
someone is speaking generally about war
and conflict and targeting different
groups we kind of shrug we're like I
look when they when they call for death
to Russians Facebook allows that now if
someone goes on Twitter and just tells
people to in like as as inputs at
imminent threat targeting a group of
people then we say okay that's crossing
the line but my my view is this we
shouldn't tolerate extremist opinions we
like we shouldn't have to pay for them
and fund them I think we can allow on on
and and agree with on social media
platforms a wide range of opinions that
we disagree with and don't like to
challenge but there's absolutely a red
line for all of us where we're like nah
like this is too much and it's like
advocating children be exposed to adult
content things like that probably
crossing the line but so the other thing
I'll mention too is I'm not here to be
the Arbiter of morality and tell you
where a system like Twitter should
determine or X where people can and
can't say things my attitude will
typically be let the crazy people say
the crazy things so we can know they're
saying it that being said if an actor
came out and did was advocating for a
whole bunch of really nasty stuff like
getting you know grooming kids and
things like that I certainly would not
want to be involved in a project with
them and I think that's fair that people
would say no to it the big difference is
we're taking back the Overton window
where the left said that saying
something like we should have
immigration controls oh you're you're
canceled you're fired that's what's
crazy that's a reasonable thing to say
yeah I think it is I mean I think part
of the desire to push the window so far
is to obscure the idea of what's right
and what's wrong I think there are a lot
of people who I wouldn't agree with
politically who would also say no I
don't want children exposed to sexual
content at a young age or
inappropriately uh but there is another
narrative especially on the Progressive
left that says oh well maybe you're
oppressing someone by by saying those
ERS are bad or condemning them they they
want there to be no Hardline no uh and I
think they want you to feel more okay
with compromising your values and that's
very that there's no way to uh maintain
a culture if that's also the energy when
I when I first went to college one of my
friends her dad said you can go to
college and keep an open mind but not so
open that your brains fall out mhm it's
a good way of putting it we got to we
got to jump to this story
cuz ladies and gentlemen we're winning
from uh Naples news comedian Matt R
Sparks controversy with joke in Netflix
special is he performing in Florida well
I chose this local news outlet for a
reason mostly because it just documents
the controversy around comedi met R he
had a Netflix special where he appeared
to mock domestic violence
victims how dare he I really really
don't care that he did and here's the
best part here's from NBC News comedian
Matt R responds to Netflix special
backlash with a link to special needs
helmets he made a post and said it for
everybody who is offended by my joke
here's a link to my apology and when you
clicked it it loaded up I wonder if they
have an image of it I don't think they
do it loaded up a a shopping website for
special needs helmets for people who are
you know differently abled as it were
get him dude I'm just saying shout out
to this comedian but we're starting to
win back see this is this is the point
about cancel culture I have almost I
would say almost no problem with the
limiting of certain speech I say almost
because we try to be very careful we
want to make sure people have right to
express themselves legitimate
legitimately but you know like people
posting adult content is not legitimate
expression for it's obscene for kids I
think it's fair to say that we're going
to be like no way this dude made a joke
that's it grow up have a nice day laugh
or don't five years ago this dude would
have been fired in two seconds look at
was it Shane Gillis was that the
comedian Shane fired from SNL like a
month of hired or something he did like
an accent or something he had done a
joke in the past uh like in those like
years ago prior on like an open mic or
something like that where he made fun of
uh asian-americans and he just saidit
that yeah he's a great impressionist by
the way and as as as an Asian-American
myself I thought it was hilarious and
they fired him because of it yep correct
we're winning this story shows we're
winning it's not just about the the
culture that's being built it's about a
this dude's 28 and he's got a Netflix
special and he's like like my joke I'm
going to double down and insult you even
further well and they I mean Bill bar
had this joke for a long time about you
know of course bar Bill Burr sorry I
don't know if Bill bar has ever had a
joke Bill Burr has had this joke where
he says you know you know they always
say there's never a reason to hit a
woman but you know is that true you
could wake me from a drunken stuper and
I could give you at least 10 or
something like that like that's like
alluding to domestic violence but people
laughed I think he did this joke on some
you know mainstream
uh late night show and so it's
interesting how it was something people
tolerated and now they're like new Young
comedian you have to fall in line or or
or stop you know what I mean it sounds
like the crowd is flailing and they're
like w my my anger that's left over from
five years ago stop and then he knows
Matt R knows if he gets fired he's good
to go like look at Shane gillis's career
is off the charts right now he's
interfacing with Rogan he's Matt R's
already been on Rogan's podcast once oh
we we we we have defeated the the the
the woke Beast is is flailing ccil
culture is dying we are succeeding
across the board Hollywood is failing
cable network news is failing the
corporate press is struggling Elon Musk
has launched this nuclear lawsuit
against Media Matters Trump truth social
has just sued 20 news organizations the
amount of Victories and the expansion of
uh of our efforts is just so tremendous
right now ladies and gentlemen you got a
lot to be thankful for this Thursday
alth stay concerned because it's like
they have the power I say they kind of
vaguely but to to turn off your money so
the whole system is is rigged up so that
Visa these central banks can shut off
your access to a bank account and no
more US dollars for you that's like
their atom bomb in the pocket so we
don't want to celebrate like we've won a
war or any kind of long-standing I mean
I I think cryptocurrency is fascinating
that we have other way Bitcoin
particularly Bitcoin I mean I like a lot
I like a lot of just the idea of being
able to you Bitcoin I'm a bit of a
Bitcoin Maxi yeah a lot of my friend are
too and they're like Bitcoin I started
in Bitcoin 2013 then bought bought in
and then we made a documentary film
called life on bitcoin where this
married couple you can run it on Amazon
and stuff but it's this do this couple
lives on bitcoin for 90 days their first
90 days of their marriage only Bitcoin
in 2013 then we got into ethereum and
other Litecoin Litecoin and all the
other coins and I was like I was
thinking about it like a technology
where I was like number two is Facebook
or number Google came after Microsoft
soft Etc so the better technology is
going to win and then by couple years
ago maybe a few years ago it I started
thinking about it more like an economist
where I'm thinking about hard money and
what it actually means and what Bitcoin
does well is money that is the one thing
it does well and it does it better than
any of the other other
cryptocurrencies Bitcoin is the money
it's the best at it well and I switched
back and I and we can take a look at El
Salvador yes right and it's just like
booming booming booming booming it's
I'm I'm just belly brought us down for
sound of freedom and did like he's the
first American country to and he
screened it dude he knows what's up that
dude's amazing and uh here's here's a
crazy story for you guys you're going to
love this one there was a a a an illegal
immigrant in the United States who
applied for Asylum claiming that he was
facing persecution in his home country
his home country was El Salvador the
persecution he was a gang member that
was going to go to jail so he comes to
the US and get this they release him and
then later we're like wait wait wait
wait what was the persecution he was oh
he's a gang member wanted for crimes
okay we got to arrest him now that's how
crazy things are up here that a guy was
like they're going to arrest me for my
group affiliation what's your group I
I'm a gang member well the operation was
like okay that makes sense press like
that they didn't even either they didn't
ask or they asked and were're like that
does seem hard I wouldn't want to go to
jail either into the US with you it's
pathetic it's going to be so great
Thanksgiving you know all everybody
who's Al with freedom meritocracy
anti-woke you're going to be sitting
there with with a smile on your face as
your woke relatives are just grumbling
and angry Biden's losing Hollywood's
crumbling they're losing money and you
can just be like I don't even need to
argue with you we're we're we're on
we're on the cusp of Victory here you
guys ever take do you take Bitcoin for
Angel Studios as currency or is that too
much reserve of Bitcoin yeah and we've
done and we have a reserve and we've
also done Bitcoin tipping with Tuttle
twins there's a whole episode on on um
on bitcoin one of our rounds we took on
a $10 million chunk of Bitcoin as a
reserve for theany yeah just kind of a
backup you just bought it just just
switched cash into bit a fund invested
in Angel and we said we'll take your
investment we'll sell stock for Bitcoin
how
long it's been a while yeah yeah so now
it's like 100 million or something no no
not that long it's still in the the same
I mean bitcoin's up to what like 36
right now I think it was 37 today 37
it's just going up I mean now that um
what's his name Javier Malay got elected
in Argentina is talking about switching
them over to bitcoin well yeah he's
first going to go to the dollar and then
his Bitcoin yeah dollar he's going to do
the same thing as Buel they those guys
are yeah they're buds I guess Bull's
coming down there to hang out with them
like for the inauguration bolaro is
going to be there yo dude that is so I
mean come on how how are people how
could anyone be pessimistic right now is
just so amazing I mean especially with
all the stuff you guys are doing I'm
just like m i I'm I'm a fan of that guy
he's oh yeah AA he's bold
a I think there were a lot of Americans
he won over you know the day after his
election because they pretending no that
he was going to do something different
yeah there was a three I think it was a
three person election and then he and
one of the others got the runoff and the
other the third person all they all
voted essentially we all just going to
vote for um La I guess announced within
21 days they will end the ministry of
diversity gender and inclusivity or
whatever he's like and there was some
tweet that was like so you there's
illegal to have a gender now in
Argentina it's like no it's illegal to
be a terrible bureaucracy that ruins
people's lives it's crazy I know it's
not even illegal it's just shutting down
a department yeah how dare like that the
department has to exist something
exactly getting rid of a department
doesn't mean you don't like the thing
that the department is named sometimes
the name isn't even I want to get rid of
the Department of Education but that
doesn't mean I don't believe in
education look at look at Public Square
you want everyone to be illiterate
you're admitting it here now you guys
like Public Square put out a statement
about their revenue they're making
millions they're expanding they launched
their uh e-commerce officially I think I
think it's officially launched right the
e-commerce on Public Square I'm just
looking at this year has been absolutely
fantastic you know the 2010s were crazy
let me stress you could not say on
Twitter men aren't women they would ban
you for that absolutely crazy look how
far we look how far we've gone and it's
cool because we do get on to all kinds
of people for saying you know the
Republicans don't do anything or like
local people just focus on National
politics they don't change anything on
communities and I do think you're
starting to see the the results of
people taking initiative and especially
in the case of Public Square seeing
something that was needed and creating
it and I think you guys are similar with
the work that you do yeah I don't know
if they take crypto yet Public Square
that's going to be interesting when that
happens would when you take if you took
Bitcoin like to watch a movie I could
pay you on bitcoin would there be like a
tax hell Unleashed upon the company for
taking Bitcoin as payment or is it past
that now or you can like take it convert
it to cash the US treats it as capital
gains tax um makes it more and they just
made a a new change to where accountants
can handle uh Bitcoin on their balance
sheet a lot easier which is going to
help companies going to make a big
difference companies that have huge cash
reserves where we're seeing inflation
like I don't know if you guys have been
at the grocery store lately but things
are getting freaking insane and uh you
know I I I it's shocking and I'm I'm not
in the lower income brackets and I'm
just can't believe how expensive it is
and so our reserves our cash reserves as
companies are losing value the longer
they sit so the more cash you have and
so there's going to be a lot more
companies coming in and saying we're
going to put a huge chunk of our
reserves in Bitcoin dude I I mentioned
this the other day we went to Weiss I I
buy these salami packs we usually have a
bunch of them downstairs for everybody
to eat they're $12 a pack now and it's
just it's just like actually that breaks
my heart more than almost anything else
is seen food go up cuz I I know like we
grew up in a family with nine kids in
Idaho and it was like a tiny income like
$113,000 a year we came from the very
lowest tier and it breaks my heart to
see people who have been saving and
working their whole lives just like
taking huge steps back because it's
theft it's theft inflation yeah the CEO
you go the CEO of strike just said that
uh the the US needs to um got to
refinance refinance their debt about 10
trillion 10 trillion over the next uh 18
to 24 months wow and he says in terms of
scale that's 3x the scale of covid so if
covid generated the kind of inflation we
just saw you refinancing that debt is
going to generate I'm not going to give
anybody Financial advice or anything
thing so don't H this advice but if if
Argentina does a a fast shift into
Bitcoin like El Salvador did Argentina
is much larger much wealthier a huge
Bitcoin is going to jump in value two or
three times I could only imagine you
said it was the CEO of strike strike
what's strike it's a it's a Bitcoin
technology you can you can just you get
a strike app it's like PayPal but you
just buy Bitcoin and you can actually
set it up to buy Bitcoin every hour so I
buy a a little bit every single hour on
strike do you guys ever they have no I
want to jump I want to jump to another
story here because then I I want to
cover this last one and then get into
the movie stuff it's just been too much
good news man ladies and gentlemen I got
such amazing news for all of you this is
from US News Maryland handgun liens your
law is unconstitutional US court rules
this is massive okay a US appeals court
this is federal on Tuesday declared that
Maryland's licensing requirements for
people seeking to buy handguns were
unconstitutional setting Landmark US
Supreme Court decision last year that
expanded gun rights let me break it down
for you in Maryland to get a gun you got
to take a safety class like a 4-Hour
program and like and then get a license
and then you can do this a lot of states
do this and now the US federal court has
just said not anymore this is a major
milestone in Universal federal
constitutional carry which we should
have cuz the the the the uh Constitution
is federal yet state by state we are
still fighting this battle over
constitutional carry now more than half
the country is constitutional carry and
those that remain the evil States they
call them the evil seven they are now
losing time and time again this will
probably get appealed we'll see what
happens if it goes to the Supreme Court
but for the time being a massive Victory
so at first we had this lawsuit it was
it was bruan I think it was bruan right
where they said you can't uh you have to
issue a permit if a permit is requested
New Jersey and Maryland and New York are
are are three examples of states where
you'd go in say I'd like to get a gun
they'd say great F out this form and the
form would say what's your reason and if
you were like I'm an American citizen
who wants to keep an bear arms they'd
say not good enough and theyd deny you
your permit or they'd lie so the Supreme
Court says no no no that's
unconstitutional you're you're borrowing
guns you have to do it Maryland and New
Jersey were and New York would not give
you a permit they'd give you one only if
you were rich or famous and could prove
you a rich and famous the other the
other way to get it is if you uh uh like
if you handle large of cash like working
at a bank they would allow you to get a
permit as a security guard but so almost
nobody gets them now they've lost that
and the latest news is they said okay
fine you can get a gun but you got to
take a class and now the courts are like
nah you don't you can have a gun so
Maryland is about to be forced by a
judicial review to become constitutional
carry this this rule is a major push we
may eventually see and I'm talking like
in a in two or three years maybe four
depending on how long it takes the
Supreme Court but we we could see in the
next several years Nationwide
constitutional carry which means you can
be in Maryland and carry concealed and
drive to any state you want and not go
to prison for doing so yeah which is
insane if you think about it because the
Constitution of the United States says
you have the right to keep in bear arms
so why is that if you go to from
Virginia to West Virginia you're fine
and if you go to Maryland now you're
committing a felony that's insane
because Maryland doesn't think you
should have a gun right and also
Maryland has you know a very intense
crime bread city city I'm talking at
Baltimore of course uh they don't know
how to handle these issues but they
think we'll ban guns and that will make
everything okay they don't understand
the problems they have because they
don't acknowledge what they're trying to
say if you look at Brazil when bosano
came in I don't agree with everything
bosano did but one of the things he did
is he said people should be able to own
firearms and crime dropped during his
period my wife's Brazilian so my kids
are all half Brazilian we spend time a
lot of time down there but crime dropped
by
30% during his his time amazing and all
the academics were trying to explain it
away and say well it wasn't because of
guns it was because
of the air other good policies that he
was implementing please name which one
he just got lucky he got it was was he
doing what they did in San Francisco
making crime legal and then not
classifying as a crime
anymore serious question I don't know no
bolaro is kind of the opposite end of
that one he's the lock him up and throw
away the key typ 30% do you know how
much of that la la like VI was violent
crime the diminish I I don't know the
all the the super details but it was it
was stunning how much impact it had
amazing jeez well I I I uh um I can't
remember which state it was but I
remember a story that I that I learned
about when I was like
18 that um I it might have been Michigan
or Wisconsin some State enacted a gun
control law and then crime skyrocketed
like 87% so they immediately uh repealed
it like oh crap that was a big mistake
and uh Illinois just outside of Chicago
has has has the a city with some of the
highest crime in in the country believe
it or not a lot of people think you're
going to get the highest crime rates in
like per City but yes there's this one
part of uh Illinois that has one of the
highest crime rates it's actually a
wealthy shopping district so it's not
murders and stuff it's just everybody's
getting robbed and mugged nonstop look
man if you live in
Illinois these criminals know you don't
got a gun is there a value to make it
constitutionally legal Statewide except
for in the big cities or just caused too
much confusion and if you ever had to
like go like I think about Tennessee
where there are three major cities
across it if you ever drive across
Tennessee what are you going to do like
go around it to avoid it at some point
you're just putting a burden on the law
abiding citizens and you're not actually
dealing with those people who don't care
about your laws and we'll bring a gun
there anyways I guess are the highways
aren't are the highways federal or are
they all state they're Federal well no I
mean they're state and federal highways
so typically the way the law is supposed
to work is if you're on a Federal
Highway an interstate you're allowed to
carry as you know under certain
circumstances typically you're allowed
to transport but if you get off at any
point for gas oh they're going to get
you I know people who had this happen to
them otherwise if you don't have this
what happens is you end up if you're in
s Pao or any area of Brazil and it
hasn't but guns have been illegal for a
long time there before bus and arrow you
have these walls that are as tall as
your ceiling and on top of the walls
it's just a bunch of broken glass
bottles cemented into the top of the
wall because people are poor they can't
afford really great security and so they
just build a big wall and put broken
glass bottles on they build a wall you
say a great idea so this is actually
crazy but around every single little
tiny house there's a wall with broken
glass bottles that's that's your last
defense when you don't have any way to
defend yourself and if you call the
police they'll show up in like an hour
oh right I mean but I mean let's be
honest that's that's how it is in the US
yeah it's starting to get that way I my
experience in Chicago has always been
that way okay I'm I'm a farm boy so
so the only see the only consideration
when you're in the rural areas is how
long will it take for them to drive
there that's right cuz they'll come as
fast as they can exact it might be 20
minutes but in the city you could have a
police station down the street and this
has happened to me and my family and had
someone you know let's just say engaging
in violence against our property and
literally a block away and the cops
didn't show up for half an hour it's CU
they're dealing with like like actual
violent murder or something or they're
passing out parking tickets yeah or they
just or they're just like is like what
are we going to do about it in the
suburbs like man that sounds really bad
we we'll stay away from there it was
okay response time in the suburbs but
out in the country like I mean 20
minutes is not acceptable I don't well
this is the reality man when when we
when I lived in Florida if we if we we
didn't have police if we called the
sheriff it was going to be an hour hour
and a half so you need a gun that I was
talking to a friend of mine who was like
there is no she told me there's
absolutely no reason anyone should have
a gun give me one reason I said okay
well I lived in uh rural Florida Florida
uh 40 m outside of Miami on a 5 acre
property and we didn't have a gun we had
a uh a break break action air uh
compression 22 pellet rifle and uh there
was a there was word going around the
neighbors that uh someone had been
murdered it was a home invasion illegal
illegal immigrants had had broken in and
killed some people and they were not
caught so one day me and my friends are
hanging out in the kitchen we're making
pizzas because we like to just make all
different kinds of pizza for fun we make
weird ones we made a fruit pizza once
with like jam and Kiwis and stuff just
off and uh I see a guy in my backyard
with a flashlight and I'm like the there
are 6 tall fences surrounding the
property and so I'm like okay I can call
Sheriff right now and maybe in an hour
and a half we'll figure it out so I'm
not going to say it's a responsible
thing to do but I uh I compressed the
air in the rifle went out dry fired bang
and I yelled hey they bolted jumped the
fence and they were gone perhaps the
smartest thing to do it's all I it's all
I could do at the time and it made me
think like we probably shouldn't be out
here unless we're able to defend our
eles and so I said okay what would have
happened if that was the murderer who
who had you know killed somebody else
and you realize it was just an airsoft
gun or or or no no I didn't have
anything I mean they hear a bang they
run for it they're not going to try and
figure out what it was it's a it's it's
it's it's a loud it's a loud weapon and
and to be honest those things are are
dangerous not as dangerous as like a
Ruger 1022 but let's say we're totally
disarmed and this guy comes up to the
property armed should I I I call the
police they'll be here in an hour and a
half what should I do you're back to the
biggest man wins she had no answer she
had no answer she's like I don't know
that person shouldn't have a gun I'm
like you're right but they have one cuz
they're committing a crime what should I
do should I just die you should tell
them they shouldn't have a gun and then
they'll be like oh my mistake I'll put
it down and let me pause the game
there's no answer the answer is you need
to be able to defend yourself from bad
people and law- abiding citizens are not
the risk yeah yeah I just and you guys
are parents like when your kids are old
enough to live by themselves would you
feel better if they like live had a gun
and knew how to how to defend themselves
if they live alone TR them on what to do
it does make sense it's weird to me that
the response to I have a fear about gun
is to ban them as opposed to train more
people to know how to operate them and
to feel comfortable with them and that
means that you're not probably not
addressing what your actual fear is
which is crime and that's a different
conversation than I remember after the
Aurora Colorado shooting I said to my
wife and I was just like I'm never like
I'm getting a gun and I have a phobia of
pistols I like not because I don't I I'm
a big supporter of self-defense in the
Second Amendment but have a phobia so
I'm going to go take classes down in
Nevada a week-long class on how to do
this and I'm going to become as well
trained as any police officer so that I
know and I have confidence that I know
how to use it and I know how to protect
myself and I'll never regret being in
like that I didn't do that right
um but I wanted I wanted to be trained I
wanted to know and to try to get rid of
the phobia yeah and according to
self-defense instructors you'll be the
guy that they run to if any pops off cuz
they all know you know what you're doing
and you'll be they'll be clinging to you
theyy just in from a super chatter
Oregon uh Oregon Oregon judge struck
down a gun control measure just within
the last three hours uhy we're winning
too fast here Harney County Judge rules
Oregon gun meas get tired of winning
measure 114 unconstitutional it looked
like they were trying to create a 30-day
uh delay for really intense roles but
they shut that down I'm get I'm getting
tired of winning guys we're just winning
too much she's going to have to get used
to well let's let's talk about what you
guys are working on now because you've
got a new movie coming out on uh not
this this week December 1st yeah the
next next week Friday this is a good one
this is a good one should we should we
play the trailer they're all good though
right no they're all good because they
all pass the guild yeah 99% of the
projects that go through the guild do
not pass because they're not like it's a
high threshold we've had major
filmmakers come in go into the guild
fail get really mad because they're like
I'm my name like you should at least
just like mov Su I'm marketable and it's
like no they didn't like it so yeah and
they're like we'll never well so the the
new movie that you guys got coming out
everybody knows sound of Freedom it was
awesome it was huge now you've got the
shift which is uh uh December 1st yep
you want to tell us about it this is our
first original this uh mirrors our story
uh we met the we met the filmmaker and
writer in 2017 his name is Brock Heasley
this guy has this most amazing story
when he was a kid his dad was actually a
pawn shop owner gunned down in
California uh ended up living was on
Rescue 911 to tell his story and then
Brock when he was h a missionary he was
his dad was shot again and his dad was
was killed so Brock wrote uh started
writing to deal with um with everything
that that uh he was going through in
life and then he and his wife went
through the worst time where they lost
lost everything they both lost their
jobs on the same day they Lo they were
just destitute and uh he made this film
with pizza money this short film and
then he said I'm going to take this over
to Angel Studios and see how the angel
Guild likes this short film and they
caught the vision of it five years ago
and uh he's gone through a process of of
uh of creating this film and it has the
score on the film just keeps getting
higher and higher and higher better and
better and better until just what was it
60 days ago or so they passed the guild
to get into theaters yep wow and so we
went ahead and said all right we're
going forward with December 1st and they
went through the guild a lot of times
meaning they resubmitted this film they
sh they they raised he took a $500 short
film made with pizza money built a uh
$6.5 million budget brought in Neil
mcdna from Banda Brothers uh Sean Aston
from Lord of the Rings and from stranger
things yes Liz tabish who plays Mary
Magdalene and the chosen Paris Patel who
plays Matthew and the chosen I mean and
then Chris palaha who's like the biggest
star on Hallmark and he's very very good
at the romance stuff which this is a
dystopian romance and he made this film
it is it is a and it's going Nationwide
firsttime director first-time writer for
a
film uh and this this is going
Nationwide on December 1st is the writer
the director y what's his name again
Brock keasley Heasley h e a s l y yeah
Easley what did he shoot the $500 thing
on how did he make that with 500 bucks
bunch of friends and favors um called
them favors from his friends and bought
bought them Pizza yep oh so and he
submitted that to Angel and then they
they caught the vision off of that and
he crowdfunded over time it took him a
while but he crowdfunded
and raed $6.5 million and build this
film wow but back when he passed the
guild my wife said she she watched the
short and she's like I don't get it Neil
I don't get why you like this film or
why the guild liked this film and then
he got to the full feature because the
the original was you know it was dark it
was this retells the story of job in
like a Sci-Fi world and she just didn't
get it then she watched the the screener
after he finished the film finished
shooting it and and uh
and she's like I love this film and and
it's testing extremely well should we
play the trailer yep all right we got a
trailer right here let's uh let's pull
it up and and play it for you guys you
guys ready here we go where's my wife I
shifted
her what do you want with
me this is not my
world I've never been to this Lake
before
never walked its
Shores but I will find my way back and I
will find my way back to my
Molly 5 years ago I was left in this
dark
[Music]
place taken from my
wife the people
here have no hope you still looking for
that wife of yours you're clinging to
scraps of rumors and then he
[Music]
arrived where's my wife I shifted
her for every choice you make there are
countless other realities where you make
a different Choice you're talking about
parallel Earths imagine having the power
to move people from One reality to the
next to shift
them what do you want with me I can make
you a king imagine everything you have
ever
wanted work for me and get back with the
woman that you love okay we go on a date
and maybe we kiss hopefully he's going
to shift you back to your wife it's a
trick if I choose you that's the last
Choice I'm ever going to
make I never leave you
alone I've seen a bunch of people like
us out there looking for a little
hope there is nothing that I won't do to
you you can't just shoot the
devil there was so much evil and
inhumanity in this world but there is
also Beauty and hope and I will find my
way back to
[Music]
her right on man I just got to say uh
you know I I like winning winning the
culture wars is fantastic sound of
Freedom was amazing I'm looking forward
to this I'm trying to pull up my local
movie theater to see if I can get
tickets right now go to but angel.com
theshift and you can see all the
different showtimes there are right now
it's almost I think we're almost to
2,000 theaters right now the the Les
lesson I learned from the second time we
watched we watched it before the show
went live is don't talk on your phone
while you're driving that guy if you
catch that one second he fcks like to
see who it is oncoming traffic I'm glad
we've learned this lesson put it on
silent ignore the
thing slow so you can get there fast
angel.com thee shift yeah so when the
guy who came up with this was
resubmitting it to the guild did they
provide him feedback on you need to
shift this I mean so it's a very
collaborative responsive what happens
when you when you go to the angel Guild
and you you sign up and we actually have
a URL for timcast where you go angel.com
timcast will let you sign up for the
guild you can go there you can become a
member of The Guild and you can start
voting on content and you get
complimentary tickets to every single
movie so when you sign up you get it's
already the guild already gets to watch
sound of Freedom they already get a
watch after death you get to watch ttle
twins early and then you're going to get
two free tickets to uh the ship you'll
get two free tickets to this new movie
called Cabrini coming out next year so
on but you're building um and you get
you get to watch the next sound of
Freedom far before anybody else does so
so angel.com
uh timcast will will get you to the
guild but with the shift he submitted to
the
guild again and again rough cuts and
there's 100,000 Guild members and so you
get several hundred to a thousand people
watching it then they give you a signal
and it comes out as a score zero to 100
usually like a re to pass you have to be
at at least a 60 on that score it's a
it's a signal of how passionate people
are about your film and like the high
60s or low 70s will put you at like 99%
audience scores on Rotten Tom sound of
Freedom was a 76 it was a 74 74 74 sound
99 to 100% on R Tomatoes it's the the
sound of freedom is the most highest
audience rated Blockbuster of all time
on Rotten Tomatoes for audiences and but
the the shift he went back I think like
12 different times and just kept getting
the signal I'm off and we don't tell you
why you're off you just see the number
you know you're not there yet and then
you can read all the comments from
everybody and try to go through the
noise and find the signal as a filmmaker
so you we're not going to tell you
what's wrong with your film but people
do provide comments they do provide
comments so that you can try to sift
through the noise and find the signal as
an artist to say uh this is what's wrong
because sometimes people give you they
say one thing but you as an artist
realize oh what's actually wrong is
something totally different and you
solve their problem in a different way
for instance they'd be like I don't like
that character but you realize that the
audio is not right on that character's
scenes exactly or you haven't made him
sympathetic enough something else sound
of Freedom there was early on people
were saying the movie is too long but
the movie wasn't too long we ended up
cutting where where what the problem was
is it went too deep at the beginning on
the difficulty of the the children right
that it just went too deep and people
couldn't get out at the end and actually
enjoy the Thriller part of the movie
because the heartache was so heavy and
so we actually cut down the director cut
down the intro of the film not a lot
when everybody was saying cut the way
the audience would respond to say it
just feels long and so you think oh I'm
going to go cut down the slow Parts not
these parts where everybody's balling
I'm going to go cut down the the
non-emotional part parts and but where
it needed to be cut down was just a
little bit in the heavier stuff cuz they
went too deep and then it felt on
because they were exhausted by the end
yeah and it cut down doesn't just mean
like shorten it means like be more just
tight yeah have a have a critical eye of
what exactly is conveying what you want
I think it's not like you're saying cut
all of your movie it's saying you know
review it it's the same thing with an
editorial piece right you could say
something with 5,000 words but if you
have one line that really conveys the
meaning that's honestly you know much
more powerful yeah and what will blow
your mind with the shift is Liz tabish
performance the the one who plays Mary
Magdalene she she shines in this I've
got a quote here that just came in from
Eric artell who's a major Tik tocker and
he said Elizabeth tabish gives the
performance of her career and if you've
seen the chosen you know she's super
good her depth and vulnerability brought
me to tears and we've seen also with
Eric um sorry with with with Chris
palaha who's the they call him sometimes
the prince of Hallmark that's his normal
work world is he does Hallmark movies
everybody who's watching right now who
watches Hallmark knows who Chris palaha
is he's a star and but he's doing
something totally different in this
movie it's a very intense
Thriller but he says it's the
culmination of his career for him
culmination of Hiser this movie and he
knows how to do romance so well so him
and Liz got this chemistry like to the
point you're just like these two uh what
what did one
person one review was like you can tell
these two people want to
procreate um
it doesn't have it doesn't show anything
Shan Aston is unbelievable Neil mcdna in
my opinion gives the performance of his
career in this movie he's great this
movie we're having especially women are
telling us that this is the best movie
Angel's done and that is a big deal when
you're thinking about now men men don't
put as high as sound of Freedom sound of
freedom is but women I think the dude
saving children is like really male
powerful it is is I got text messages
from FS are like can we go kill some
pedophiles after they watch the movie
like like H that's not that's for law
enforcement and for yeah yeah but that's
how they feel simar to the let me them
with the Patriot right the Patriot is
like people are like yeah this is a
great country I feel good at this I mean
I think men and women watch film and TV
and movies for a different emotional
reaction so interesting so women love
this movie it's like and and it is
selling out all over the country there's
movie theaters selling out all over the
country and we're up against Napoleon so
it's a it's a hard I heard bad things
about who's playing Napoleon someone
well-known actor
oh yeah's amazing but the when you watch
this some some of we one one one person
said after they watched it they're like
with Chris palaha they're like it's like
my brain is like this is a this is like
if Christopher Nolan directed a Hallmark
film yeah it feels like they took the
guy out of office space and like shifted
him into that reality where he's he just
has he kind of looks like like uh what's
his name from off you can't describe
this he's also the handsome guy on a
Marvel movie he's in Marvel Avengers
he's in Avengers end game yeah but in
the credits he's handsome man
oh in the guild is there um a
discrepancy between he's a very
good-looking man between I I agree
actually very good-looking I'm glad they
cut his face up for the movie CU he stop
getting tip
cast did do you have a uh the male to
female ratio in the guild is that
noticeable in the way they vote yeah so
the women rate this super high the men
don't start rating it high until the
special effects and the sound design
came in so women started rating this
really high early on because they don't
care if Sci-Fi movies just look like
people walking around with plastic guns
until you add in all the sound design
going and the and the lasers and the you
know once all that stuff came in the men
are like yeah this is an awesome movie
but the women were on board before that
because they're like this love story is
palpable when you're waiting the votes
from The Guild do you ever take into
account the females a lot of females
voted a nine a lot of men voted a three
so
let's more on yeah we're focused we
actually shifted the focus of our
marketing this trailer is a little more
male focused but we we've shifted a lot
of it towards the romance side because
this is a lot of people say this feels
like Hunger Games which is a teenage
romance dystopian romance right it's
a does have Hames VI I get that it's it
got a kind of a Hunger Game in fact it's
trailer front of the it's trailering in
front of Hunger Games right now
interesting so if you watch that's just
through the the trailer it gives that
Bible if you go watch if you go watch
Hunger Games in uh in Regal you're gonna
see this trailer in front of but like
for a different movie that's more
romance Vibe you would have a different
trailer yeah we have focuses on romance
for women the story of job which is this
is a re modern telling of the story of
Job for for the the more faith oriented
groups and then you've got the the
Thriller element which is for men like
that men come for the the Sci-Fi is that
common when you're making trailers to do
one for women and one for men we we line
them out and we say this is going to
this group this is going to this group
that you know you're like any other
marketing can I ask demographic
information you have about the guild
like is you guys are based uh in Utah is
is that where the guild was or do you
find that they're so the GU made up so
the the the initiation of the guild came
all from investors and because we are
regulated by the SEC and finra for
crowdfunding um it was a US censor group
except for the angel investors and do
you feel that but do you feel like
that's represented in the people who
participate like do you feel like you
have a broad selection of people from
across the
country if you go to angel.com timcast
you can now sign up for a membership
anywhere in the world and so um The
Guild is growing very quickly but it's
not Utah but it's not not it's it's
every single state that's interesting
you have almost I think 200 the website
says 175k yeah 175,000 W I'm just
wondering if it's like you know Word of
Mouth like you guys are in your
community and saying we're starting
thing so your friends sign up and it
grows from there or if it is something
that you know the more you get your
friends to sign up the more weight your
culture has on the guild like timcast
fans all come and sign up then when when
you bring a movie to Angel you're much
more likely to succeed because your
demographics more represented and I
there are cities Across America I
remember I mean Texas there are a couple
um I think Matthew a couple other actors
who are trying to push Texas growing its
film industry I mean obviously Atlanta
has like a film industry right now there
are states across the US that have a
film industry that exists it's just not
as big as Hollywood right this was shot
in Birmingham it was a Birmingham crew
Birmingham Alabama shot and
Birmingham surprisingly is a very
dystopian looking place for a film wow
wow yeah it's just it's got a lot of
rundown buildings a lot of beautiful
architecture there's a scene and we
needed beautiful architecture with the
rund down look there's a scene in here
like the climax scene is in this old
historic building uh remind mic Temple
yeah but who spoke there like it Martin
Luther K Lu Luther King spoke there yeah
he spoke at that in that same spot where
the final scenes are he yeah was where
he or where you see him like on the
screen looking at his wife yeah Martin
Luther King Jr spoke there so do you
find that there are a lot of people in
the film industry who are reaching out
to you to say I want to be involved with
Angel Studios but I'm not based
Hollywood I'm based over here doing
whatever like is it sort of becoming
something people reach out to not just
to get their film made but for their
professional careers yeah yeah yes I
mean we can only right now Angel only
accepts um what we call a torch and this
harvests back to the beginning of of
crowdfunding so the Statue of Liberty
originally Frederick bartold he made a
torch he took it around Europe to raise
money he took it around the US he
couldn't get governments to pay for it
actually had to crowdfund the Statue of
Liberty right and a d back in the day
when governments didn't just cut checks
for everything so every so the French
and the American people saw that torch
and they caught the vision for what he
was trying to create and the same way
somebody brings a torch a video a short
film or a full film if it's going to go
to theaters like sound of freedom and
then the guild looks at it they catch
the vision of where they're trying to
head with it and they vote yay or nay
mhm but if I were like a cameraman and I
was based in you know North Carolina do
do you have people reaching out for
those kind of production type jobs or do
you have to direct them somewhere else
so each in each each production has its
own casting department and uh you know
David's being uh done in South Africa
we've got Productions in the UK David's
a film about King David it's an animated
musical that's coming in 2025 it's a $62
million film that they CR crazy yeah um
and so these are done in different
places The Chosen is shot in both go and
Utah and just outside of Dallas Texas um
uh so you know and the shift crew it's
got the the guys who did the music for
The Chosen Dan hasseltine and Matt uh
Matthew Nelson Matthew Nelson are did it
and it's phenomenal like the score on
this is unlike anything you've ever
heard there's nothing generic about it
yeah those guys did Jars of Clay the the
band back in the day yeah they they've
scored now the Chosen and this and
they're two of the best movie scorers
like they're just but it doesn't sound
anything like the chosen SC it sounds
nothing like it then then you've got um
the one of The Producers is was the
editor for sound of
freedom and he also edited Cabrini which
is coming out in March and then so there
is a cross pollination happening between
the groups so like Alejandro monverde
who directed sound of freedom and
Cabrini came in and consulted to help
Brock get to the point where he could
pass the guild right cuz he was was
trying to figure out how to get a score
up and Alejandro said well if you did
this or if you did this you know like
profal feedback he gave some really
great ideas or the the creators of
Tuttle twins spent some time on it and
so these different filmmakers join
around you once you've kind of reached
this point where you're where you're
building a film yeah because they need
you to succeed as well because it's part
of the community but to be honest to
your question Hannah like we're not
replacing the Hollywood craft like these
Productions they're using sag actors
they're using teams that are part of the
Hollywood uh Network because Hollywood
is better at making movies than anyone
else in the world men and they're
they're not ideologically opposed to
this well I was going to say I think
it's interesting because we talk about
building culture and you know movies and
I think that's great and excellent but I
would think all the people that need to
make the film or you know not it's not
just the actors or the people cutting it
together it's also the people holding
the mics and the people with the cameras
like those skills have ties to
Hollywood making great art they don't
care if the art is nihilistic or if it
Praises God or if it's in between
somewhere they don't care as long as
it's great art what they don't like
making is campy cringe stuff so they
want something better they don't want to
just make the same five movies over and
over again right to reach the level
that's required Gatekeepers that are the
problem to reach the level that's
required for the angel Guild you pretty
much have to have that level of craft
which means you're calling on the
resources of the storytelling world to
do that so if people are interested they
have to get involved in the casting
groups and they have to get involved in
acting and work their way up in the
industry and then they'll have a chance
um but what we saw is that the problem
with Hollywood is that it's become too
insular it's become a bubble and very
few people make these story decisions
and then they're they're they're pushing
their views on the world and the way the
stories are told because they hold the
keys to the gate those are the only
stories that get out those only the
stories to get out and we're replacing
The Gatekeepers
weing it right at the same point where
it stopped working do you are you ever
concerned that like having Alejandro
come in and advise um oh his
name yeah to advise Brock is going to
create a similar problem where a lot of
the genres are it's a similar genre
because a lot of the interactivity
amongst the artists is going to except
for Brock was already so far down the
road he's more helping him solve it's
like a mechanic saying hey the the I I
can diagnose
the problem with your storyline that
you're facing let me let me give you the
diagnosis and here a couple of ideas to
solve it and then Brock went and solved
it in his own way right and and Brock
actually like the first time that the
first ideas to try to solve it actually
didn't work but the combination of those
two ideas they got to a solution and uh
but Brock made the final call on what
was on what it was I would imagine he'd
already have the vision prepared and
that he's just doing technical crafting
at that point but you know yeah there's
just it was really in this case it was
probably really mostly about just
clarifying making sure that the story
came of knowledge Stu yeah came through
really really clear yeah a lot of you
know your story so well you don't
realize why exactly when the writer
directs their own work that's a not a
big problem but can pose a big problem I
think George Lucas had that problem with
some of the news the new episode one for
instance is just like a fantasy in his
head I didn't understand what the point
of that movie was to be honest um at all
there was no villain it was very weird
no poorly done villain with Darth Maul
so I think getting the out of the
writer's hands or having an adviser come
in that can help you maybe direct or
from the sidelines be just so you know
just cuz you see it and know it doesn't
mean the audience does what else is
coming Cabrini we got Cabrini coming
we've got um there's actually a slate of
eight next year and we're shooting for
12 in 2025 we're we're building a young
Washington movie where that kicks off a
it's a movie first we're doing it with
John Irwin who did uh Jesus Revolution I
can only imagine American under American
Underdog he's the has the most A+ Cinema
scores of any director in Hollywood so
John's building one on the founding of
America with young Washington and his
goal is to release that next year he's
got to pass the Guild of course but um
the idea is to launch something similar
to The Chosen around the entire founding
of America a universe yeah a universe
around the founding of America because
it's not we haven't gone into very much
I'd love to play Ben Franklin I don't
know if he was fat when he was young
let's roll you actually got you could do
that
thing
anything take that kite up in the air I
don't know how how deep into George's
life it's going to go that's going to be
really fun then the um so we've got that
one we've got another one called
Homestead that Neil mcdunn is in as well
and it's an end of the world one where
uh every all the power goes out nuclear
bomb hits and they're trying to survive
on a homestead essentially it's it's
based in our time um then there's bonhof
Fredick Bon Hofer famous Pastor from
Germany that fought against Hitler he
was the most famous Pastor in the
country at the time and he he has one of
like his biographies are some of the
best selling books ever and but but Bon
Hofer goes from pacifist Christian to
saying I will help try to assassinate
the fur fur wow and and the the the the
the difficulty of him trying to figure
out as a Christian as a Christian what
he should be doing and that that film is
that's a big budget one that one we just
signed like a week ago um there is David
it's a musical it's like Prince of Egypt
cool it's the Old Testament uh the and
it's this beautiful animated movie for
kids and because David was a musician he
wrote the book of Psalms which is just a
book of songs it it's actually like
motivated so if you go to angel.com
timcast and you join the angel Guild you
get a vote on all the different projects
and then you're going to get
complimentary tickets to every single
time we release a theatrical release and
what this does you have 175,000 people
right now in the guild but imagine it
once you get a million people in The
Guild then let's
say let's say half of them turn up to
theaters it's just they complimentary
tickets you TOR Swift Taylor Swift every
single movie that's how we change the
culture exactly no one can compete with
you the point because they're going to
be like they've got it natural pole are
you familiar with the like what's a
venue's natural poll what's a you so if
with with you guys having a guild you're
like oh our movies basically guaranteed
to sell out X many seats because of the
amount of people who love movies that's
right so more filmmakers come because
there's guaranteed seats and right now
we we've got 175,000 which means we're
we're doing a lot of pre-sales but once
we hit a certain point it's Unstoppable
right and you so when you're joining the
angel Guild you're joining this movement
where you get to pick the content it's
not us we're not the ones picking it you
get to trust whatever comes out you
trust what comes out you know it's all
going to be good because the bigger the
guild gets the better it picks and then
you get complimentary tickets to two
complimentary tickets to every single
movie in theaters and you're launching
these things into the into the
stratosphere and the Silver Screen when
you go in and you have a communal
experience at the theater it changes
people like you can't push pause there
is something about not being able to
press pause even if you have to hold it
for a little bit to go to the bathroom
there's a different experience when you
go to the theater it's it's like Andrew
Peterson's uh Blog the rabbit room talks
about this the sacrament of the cinema
where it's almost like a sacramental
experience where you walk into church
you give up all your distractions and
you focus on the the sacrament and what
it means about Jesus Christ and what he
did for you and it allows you to
recharge and people are desperate to get
away from these when you're looking at
the failures of Hollywood MH so let me
tell you what's fascinating you guys
have almost 200,000 Guild members and
you're talking about if you got to a
million Guild members you're these are
people who are contributing to a a like
movement it's a movement but the amount
of Revenue being erated will will make
people in Hollywood weep as they're
losing money like crazy you guys are
taking off and producing movies based on
what the guild actually is a
decentralized voting process to
determine good movies not only do you
have a better mechanism for creating
profitable films people are directly
involved in making those of those films
whereas Hollywood is top down garbage
and it's failing I'm just very happy to
see Hollywood get their comeuppence more
and more every day now you know you know
be great Hollywood stops the woke
garbage starts making good movies with
good messages good values and then we
say okay great you know the that would
be a win that that would be a win it
would be a great win that would be
amazing but you know what I'll take
Angel Studios taking over and becoming
the next biggest thing where they've got
guaranteed seats in the theaters where
movies are like sound of freedom and
less like some of the the world G they
it's not just a bunch of repeats right
we can launch if we have a guild that's
passing great content they can launch
risky risky movie to the to the Moon
right it doesn't have to be it doesn't
have to be IP that that has franchise
potential the IP is the guild yes it's
right yeah because there's automatic Buy
in right and and think about this my
kids whenever they're watching too much
screen time I have six kids when they're
watching too much screen time I go to
them I'm like kids Harmons live on the
other side of the screen we make the
content that other people do we
celebrate by watching once in a while
but we live on the other side of the
screen what we're trying to do with
Angel Studios is all the content free in
the angel app you go to the angel.com
and you can just watch all of our shows
for free you get Early Access with the
guild like sound of Freedom right now is
just in Early Access but you get to
watch everything for free but you join
the community to build a movement to
change the future of entertainment and
live on the other side of the screen do
you you get it's like Legos you spend
more time building than you do playing
because it's more fun and you get to
help make the movies that are coming out
you get to watch the early Cuts you if
you were in the did you give him that
video of that guy talking about the
shift I did it's uh it should be in the
email if you want to watch this guy that
up in M only we need to go to super
chats before we do do you ever do shoot
movies at the house with the kids I
actually like I gave him my old iPhone
and for Christmas last year and said
here's here's the phone and I only put
iMovie on it and just said go make your
own so they're using their dolls and
they're trying to you should direct them
all get them to be actors in your movie
one time they're going to love it no cuz
Harmons are on the other side of the
screen can't be actors well and here's
here's what I love about this is that
all growing up and everybody I know
who's in Hollywood they all say my
family was terrified that I Jo came to
Hollywood and 95 plus percent of people
who go into Hollywood end up losing
their faith and or their family or their
families and I want like for me success
means that in when I
old that my kids and my grandkids can be
encouraged to go into the Hollywood
business into the film business and not
worry about being destroyed with their
families and their faith and I we've got
to build a parallel system to do that
let's get it let's go to super chats for
now if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel head over to
timcast.net Discord server with
like-minded individuals a lot of really
cool stuff going on a lot of new
projects in the works there's morning
shows the people in the Discord actually
have their own Hangouts you should
definitely be involved but for now let's
read what y'all got to say Alpha turkey
just in time for Thanksgiving with the
first Super Chat saying hello there well
thank you for that Super
Chat do you think Alpha turkeyy is
really stressed this time of year or you
think it's no Alpha turkey ain't got
nothing to worry about that's true if
you're not dead by you're probably okay
be careful with deep frying turkeys I I
would suggest not to deep fry a turkey
keep seeing videos of them going up in
Flames I've always wanted to try it yeah
but you do it right and it's amazing oh
W you do it right you just have to have
a big enough space yeah right yeah cuz
the water will not water no it's it's
the water in the turkey that the oil so
you got to do it you got to know what
you're doing Matthew Emon says could you
two talk to Ryan long and Danny
polishchuk about Distributing a movie
with timcast could could the Harmon
Brothers so uh we mentioned this with
Danny the other day on the show uh Danny
said that he wrote a script he and Ryan
wrote a script but it's kind of dated
wouldn't work now and I was like let's
do a movie and they said okay so you
know I have no idea what I'm doing I
don't know maybe you guys would be or
the guild I should say not you guys you
you guys don't matter at all no Farmers
from Idaho right we help Market it once
it gets through we help take it to the
world yeah but uh Ryan long will be here
next week and uh Daniel will be coming
back and I'm going to talk to them about
you know what do we have to do to make a
good comedy film uh and our principles
so so as you're as you're prepping if
you want to come to Angel
our principles we have what's called we
we're looking for projects that amplify
light you want to explain that's stories
that are true honest Noble just
authentic admirable lovely and excellent
It's like a romcom yeah could work
totally could work fine yeah well we'll
see we'll see how edgy Ryan and and and
Danny want to get with it because
they're they're pretty they're pretty
edgy but uh you know we'll see what
happens we'll talk to him let's uh let's
grab some more what we got here Bears
fan in cheeseland are you are you're in
wiscons new subscriber here thanks for
the content I imagine that means you
live in Wisconsin you're a fan of the
Bears bold of you to admit that I
remember the first time I went to
Wisconsin I was really disappointed
because we went to a a store like a
grocery store and the cheese was
imitation cheese product and we're like
what we're in Wisconsin how did this
happen that should be treason whoever
runs that grocery store should be
brought up on state charges invitation
cheese product I don't know it was a
little store there they were doing all
right Noah Sanders says congrats on
getting scnr back up it's awesome to see
the movies you're making I just got laid
off so be on the lookout for a resume
stay blessed yes scanner it's uh
officially come back so let me tell you
the story my friends as much as we can
we did a crowd fund several years ago
it's a long time ago now this is like
what 2019 or something uh before oh yeah
yeah oh geez it was before that it was
2018 yeah it was 18 wow we raised a
million dollars in 22 hours it was the
fastest uh uh uh crowd investment in the
us at the time and we launched a company
called subverse to produce news and
documentaries and ground and field
reporting
and uh let me just give you the simple
version of it there was a lawsuit you
can read the documents they're all
public I can't say much about it because
of the lawsuit but uh it basically froze
the company in a matter of speaking we
have resolved those issues and since the
resolution which was quite a while ago
we uh I should say there was a court
resolution followed by long period of
cutting you know tying up loose ends and
resolving a lot of these issues which
finally resulted in us as of today
officially relaunching the timcast news
team is now the scnr news team they're
back and uh we're glad it's it's
happening we're working with of course
bill otman of Mines is is involved for
sure we're really excited that uh we're
going to have this this project so there
were a lot of people who had invested in
it and I'll tell you the frustrating
thing people are saying like I demand
answers you know I invested in this
project it's like I am I am legally not
allowed to to say anything when when
you're involved in these uh these cases
so it's like I you can't even respond to
someone say sorry all we can do is say
here please read this this legal
document that was published have a nice
day can't say anything so it's been
resolved we still can't you know this is
like how it works we for the for the
most part can't talk about it but anyone
who wants to can read all of the court
documents see for themselves exactly
what happened and just know that we
never stopped working on the project and
the project is back and uh we are going
to bring it back from uh what I would
only describe as insolvency you can read
all about the the court case to
understand what I'm talking about but uh
it's going to require a lot of heavy
lifting on on all of our parts but um
it's what needs to happen it's what
should happen and the people who invol
who invested in that project all those
years ago still have their stake as it
stands so good on you take take yeah
keep we went through a similar
experience big lawsuit crowdfunded
company and uh we had we went through
bankruptcy and you had people being like
why aren't you giving me every all the
information you're like you can't say
anything yeah they don't it's it's it's
it's hard to exactly even explain why
but for the basics of it is like there's
strategic and legal reasons they're like
you cannot talk about this yep if I like
someone totally unrelated the way court
systems work court systems work that way
to where if you say something you're
actually potentially hurting all their
Investments right oh and then it just
opens up the door for a lot more so uh
as it pertains to this I think the like
the official thing is the people
involved in the company cannot speak of
or induce anyone to speak of
what happened but but if I were to just
do it and then I'm not evolved at all
and then you're like well here's a link
to a video of a guy explaining it that's
legal no not you can't get do that yep I
can't even be like watch this gu I can
say here are the court documents you can
read them for yourself that's it if if
anybody were to make a video I could not
be like oh look at this video can't do
it it's crazy it's crazy how that works
and uh let's just say we're all very
disappointed but we're excited that
things are are getting brand is hot dude
scanner
I like you it's a very sci-fi and we had
a lot of great stuff we had a lot of
great stuff and uh if anyone's wondering
what happened you can read the court
documents cnr.com right now looking at
it yeah looks good so and it's just
getting started we just we got something
up that we could we we we had to do a
lot of infrastructure work it was
expensive and it's worth it and it's uh
uh I'm excited for it but uh there's a
lot of other stuff involved you know
we're going to be working on
documentaries the stuff from elot is now
going to be published on scanner the
Twitter account will stay the same and
Tim cast news is going to be uh
reposting these things and and uh
timcast news of course will use the
Articles as sources and things like that
but uh timcast news will not be
publishing uh day-to-day news stories
however Tim cast.com still will have
special articles and things like that
and uh nothing else is is changing so
super excited all right let's go let's
let's see let's see what we got zakus
and branagan deeds says saw after death
this week thanks Tim when can we look
into a running running a coffee shop I'm
an entrepreneur in Oregon and would like
to counterculture here so uh this the
the Snowballs rolling down the hill the
good news is I'm hearing from uh the the
people working on the project things are
picking up speed the equipment has
arrived and we hopefully will have this
up and running it was supposed to be we
thought it was going running earlier
this year that's how crazy it was we
bought a building we like started doing
all the work and then all of a sudden
permits resulted in oh you got to fix
this you got to fix this you got to fix
this and it just never ended and uh but
we're we're getting there and uh we're
working with Chef Andrew grul on on the
expansion plans so stay tuned for that
super exciting and then we're building a
uh oh you know what we need to do we're
building an anti-time Square in
Martinsburg West Virginia so this is
where we're putting our coffee shop
right and so we were talking with uh
Terrence Williams about a cousin teas
Diner because he's got cousin te's
pancakes and I'm like the doal diner is
like going out of business and we don't
know what's going on we should we should
revive it cousin teas Diner we should do
a series of businesses all downtown
Martinsburg that are parallel economy we
got to put up an angel Studios movie
theater in Martinsburg West Virginia
that would be so cool yep and then it's
just that'd be really fun yeah you have
the new movies you have regular movies
in rotation that you guys want to have
ones that fit fit your values but also
just like and ones that ones that you
guys get behind Tim cast we the movies
you really like we could go do special
screenings there but documentaries cuz
we just put out infringed so there's a
lot you could do I don't up to you guys
but uh We've uh Terence Way's definitely
interested in in in something he he
actually gave us the idea by mentioning
he wanted to do this Diner and we have
the paperwork with Andrew gr we're
finalizing and then we are going to the
general idea is we want to create we've
got all these prominent individuals that
are fighting the culture war and I'm
like let's create brick and mortar shops
for all these different personalities
that fit their brand for what they're
interested in and into and promoting and
then set up up all over the country so
with cast brew coffee I'm like imagine
imagine if we we had a thousand of these
through coffee shops yeah coffee shops
now imagine this imagine some some guy
or woman walks in for their morning
coffee and as they're waiting for it
there's a TV screen playing Crowder
timcast IRL or some other show people
you know Joe Rogan whatever that's going
to expose our side of of the culture war
and parallel economy to regular people
when we put this up next to you know a
Walmart or something y now imagine
Saturday night at the coffee shop is you
know normal hours are till 8 but this
night we're doing a screening for an
angel Studios you know movie that came
out a little while ago come hang out get
together what what we want to do is
something called Saturday morning
cartoons where on Saturday mornings
families come with their kids the TVs
are playing wholesome cartoons we do
catering and this creates like a like
builds up Community between families and
we got cartoons we could help you out
with their exactly Tuttle twins Tuttle
twins WIA Saga David Young David yeah
but uh an angel Studios movie theater in
Martinsburg that'd be cool send us the
we'll figure it out we're so we're we're
so far away from it I mean I feel like
if there was someone who was uh uh like
a billionaire culture Warrior they could
be like I'll hire 10 guys right now
we'll get the ball rolling for me it's
like we got 800 things you know on all
these different you know so the
paperwork's moving forward with with
Jeff Andrew grul but we can only go as
fast as we can so hopefully the the
fastest way to get there I think to that
is if we can get the angel Guild big
enough to escape velocity yeah
essentially like we just need to figure
out kind of a deeper partnership to
where we're working with everybody who's
like-minded and making sure it's a win
for everybody there's a theater across
the street from us that hosted an all
ages drag show perhaps we can buy it and
turn it into a movie theater and stop
having those kinds of things yeah the
people in the community are really
pissed off because they had a pride
event where they had children dancing
with the with drag queens and stuff like
that and the locals are are offended I
mean they they find this stuff to be in
violation of West Virginia state law
which they they clearly outline and
they're wondering why why nothing's
being done about it well it's because
wokeness pushes its way into these these
areas and so we're you know we're going
to we're going to push back and say look
man if the if the people who live here
are saying this this goes against their
values and they have laws against it we
need something to change so and we'll
see where we go with it talk about after
death much and I do want to keep going
with super chats but how's it doing this
is the documentary you guys released a
few months ago or bestselling
documentary since Co period and it's the
number one Faith documentary in history
it's about people experiencing really
like life after death like um what do
they call it near-death experiences and
things like that yeah and it's in the
guild right now if you if you become a
member of The Guild you can actually
just watch it right now oh really just
because we just as as we're moving
Thanksgiving it's moving out of theaters
because the big movies are coming in
which means it's going straight into the
guild and Guild gets everything first so
if you go to the angel.com timcast you
can just start watching this but this
movie what they do is they go through
and they take the scientific
documentation around what people have
experienced when they died and and they
came back you know people have been were
dead completely like Nob brain activity
type situations for 30 minutes or 90
minutes from multiple continents
different faiths uh just all types of
people looking for patterns and then
they look for patterns and they see that
like there are people who are in
surgeries and have experiences where
they see things that are happening and
they explain it to the surgeon after the
fact and the surgeon's like they can't
know that it's impossible for them to
know that because they're having an out
of- body exper
wow stuff like there' be a coin up on
top of something and they'll see the
coin they describe the tools yeah
they'll describe what the doctor's tools
that that they're using to operate on on
them and I've heard that uh they there
was a a a cupboard where they they're
watching their own ambulance get to the
hospital and they're following it they
wrote someone wrote something on a paper
and had it on top of like a a cupboard
and then someone who was having a near
near-death experience said what was on
top of it and they were just like how
could you have possibly known there was
no point at which you were consciously
walking around the room you were on your
deathbed the whole time and they were
like I saw it here's what it says
everything's vibrating and your soul is
attuned to that well and they talk about
as more real this is what's crazy almost
all of them say this experience was more
real to me than life I was alive and
then I was more alive More Alive do they
ever you know oh that's that's
freaky I think it's purported to lose
seven grams when the human body dies
have you guys ever heard of that I've
heard that on your death experience do
they lose seven and then regain the
seven I don't know like some of these
guys are like completely crushed in car
accidents and their bodies are
completely like destroyed dead for 90
minutes yeah clinically like there
there's stuff that's just Bonkers that's
they're they're drowned for significant
periods of time and um and about 23% of
afterdeath experiences reported are a
hellish experience and then the rest
describe it as light and love and uh so
it's after death it's technically
they've died and then they come back to
life yes yeah crazy and even like
there's um when when you go and watch it
inside the app when you get in the angel
app and you watch it there are dozens of
videos of people that have watched the
movie and then they submitted their own
experiences yes so there's a community
of people joining in there saying hey
this is what I experienced this is what
I experien I read a book on this 20
years ago 19 years ago and uh it was
fascinating because it was like it was a
skeptic who wrote a book who was an a an
atheist secular guy who said that you
know his goal was basically to analyze
this in any as through any other
academic survey and what he found was EV
uh n like 80 to 90% of the interviews he
did it was almost the same story
regardless of external circumstance like
the a lot of people say oh they see a
bright light cuz they're in an operating
table and he was like actually we found
that people who are having near-death
experiences outside of Hospital settings
car accidents uh gunshot wounds Etc
experienced the same thing either and
and they meet relatives they have they
have life
reviews like that's something that's
different than likey reviews yeah they
have instead of psychedelic experiences
they'll meet their relatives or they
meet like uh they meet God and then they
have a Life review where they go through
their life with like in the Scrooge
movie right yeah kind of it's really
interesting how some of these movies
that do really well if you look at It's
a Wonderful Life he goes back through
his life and he overcomes his trauma and
he's healed and in Scrooge he go these
writers tapped into something deeper
about how our like more eternal because
they're going back through their lives
in these stories and then they're
completely healed by the end of the
movie and these resonate deeply with
people well and it comes at a time when
therapy speak is on the rise you have
lots of people especially young people
and I applaud this who say you know I
want to get better I want to understand
myself more or whatever else but it's
like are you actually fully reflecting
on your life and the choices you made
are you holding yourself right true
honesty Let's uh let's read some more
Super chats we got T-Rex Pet Shop says
judge in Georgia just ruled the cyber
security flaws of voting machines
unconstitutional I saw that big win for
voting security what kind of food will
you get for Sheamus the type from T-Rex
pet shop right yes yes we will uh so
well that's good news um Sheamus is in
his cage and uh he's he's very he's very
nice and he's been getting along and
he's he's very hungry he will eat
anything and just snarl it down but uh
we like the vet said that he's very
loving has had human cond before so all
if he loses a litter box then he's good
to come inside probably not in the
castle because this is Bokus territory I
was thinking the same thing yeah B can't
be stress Sheamus is little right he's
like no he's big no no I me age yeah
he's uh I I I uh uh yeah he's like eight
or nine months and this is crazy because
once we got news that Mr Bokus was sick
I I was asking like should we get a
kitten so that Bokus can teach the
kitten and then when Bokus passed is cuz
he's he's really sick then the kitten
will have that spark of Mr bcus and the
crazy thing is around this time within a
within a month or two of this Sheamus
was born and then lived on our property
over the past several months and was
living in our garage and now we have uh
he's probably eight to 10 months 10
months old brought him to the vet got
him shots and got him no fleas no ticks
he got dewormed all that good stuff and
he's uh he's fat and happy has the
cartoonist publicly commented on uh
being demoted to the second Sheamus or
demoted when was he ever the first
Sheamus he was the only Sheamus Clair I
I assume he was demoted because you
didn't you know offer him the first the
number one slot even though he had been
around for a while no he was just
replaced by a cat he was D ranked cuz
he's a thief so he was the just kidding
Sheamus it's mostly just a joke it's
mostly we were driving the car we were
driving the car and I was calling the
cat Mumu and because I was saying meu to
it and then we were like we should come
up with the name and then you know as
we're driving to go get food with
Sheamus I was like we're going to call
him Sheamus cuz Sheamus is leaving and I
was like that way when Sheamus is gone
we can still say something like oh oh no
Sheamus pooped on the floor again
yeah comedy never ends Sheamus right
it's fun to say that and then when I was
walking outside talking to Alison I was
like we got to take Sheamus to go get
his balls cut off and then Sheamus walks
and I was like not you talking about
Sheamus one not Sheamus 2 yeah we should
never talk about Sheamus 2 cuz he leaves
he's flaky he's into cartoons he's a
weirdo Mr bcus is actually doing a lot
better I think it's the stem cells yeah
and he's eating a lot more his kidney
function improved he gained weight going
to let the Pharmaceuticals like go easy
on the Pharma cuz they will just be like
hey here's another pill oh it has side
effects here's another pill to count the
side effects but before you take that
here's another pill to counter affect
the side it's like dude this happens
with dogs this is a cat apparently just
modern veterinary medicine like pill
pill pill pill pharmaceutical yeah stem
cells are magic it's like a new te
here's what happens with a lot of people
just medicine in general someone uh gets
a cough so they say take this pill for
your cough the cough causes dehydration
they say okay now take this liquid
solution for yourh the pill causes
dehydration and right right right and
then right yeah the pill causes
dehydration and then they're saying okay
well now you got to take this pill to
counteract that side effect and then
eventually you're on seven pills and
you're like I'm taking all these pills
to counteract all the problems from the
other pills meanwhile they're all slowly
hurting you in some way it's just I in
my opinion I don't know enough I'm not a
doctor but I see I watch with my own
eyes the guy struggling to move around
and after the seventh pill and I'm like
no no no no let the body heal all right
shider Alpha says my favorite Mr Beast
video is after recent backlash I will be
re blinding 1,000
people like what do people expect from
this dude I I I think it's great that Mr
BEAST's whole brand is like I'm going to
do a really good thing for people to get
famous and make money and I'm like okay
like that's like that's amazing yeah
like what else should we be doing like I
don't know selling cheeseburgers it's
fine too I guess and got started
somebody's going to get famous that's a
really good reason to be famous and
there are like YouTubers who've gotten
in trouble for like being like oh we're
going to host this competition and it's
going to raise money and we'll donate it
to charity and then they don't they're
going to go back in time and be like we
can't celebrate Mother Teresa because
she helped so much in some because Mr V
films the stuff like at least there is
evidence that he's doing the stuff he
says he's going to do he's not like
telling you a story and there's a lie
behind it yeah he doesn't he's not like
next week we're going to I mean he just
puts out the video and he also didn't
get famous doing this stuff he got
famous grinding 10 12 hours a day making
Minecraft content and then he put that
money into doing this great stuff like
paying off his mom's house and all right
yeah it's pretty amazing beans says Ian
the moment when you asked Ron Paul if he
plays Dungeons and Dragons that was the
Pinnacle moment of podcasting my sides
have not yet returned from orbit oh good
yeah I needed to know in order to have
the conversation properly yes yes I
wonder if he's checked it out since
operation outstanding in field says I'm
joining the Cavalry I've upgraded to
Premium and plus I'm buying ads 10K now
uh till end of 2024 promoting my GBS and
mandated uh jab videos Hold the Line ask
Elon Musk lawsuit on MM Chris bosski
Seth Dylan Tim cast the quartering
cobrate adbis here here thanks for the
Super
Chat lethal strain says Matt rif is
attacked the same time ebram x kend's
movie comes out on Netflix oh did it I
don't know who cares yeah that guy's
that guy's fizzling out good it's a good
time it's a good time squid bugs
Anonymous says mle vowing to dismantle
regulation on an already crumbling
Society seems like a great way to see
more corruption exploitation economic
inequality and environmental destruction
nice try absolutely not cutting all
those costs are going to be great for
decentralization to start solving it
solving its own problems which I look
forward
to what have we
here poison fist says New York appet
Court tossed quarantine Camp lawsuit
Paving the way for government kidnapping
cing hospitalization detainment without
evidence and diagnosis yikes we saw that
bill during Co where New York said that
if they think you're sick they can just
take you and lock you
up welcome to your Brave New World did
you see Kathy hok's press conference
today where she was like we're gonna
expand the division of Homeland
Securities um like basically she's
saying like on college campus we're
going to have additional training so
that we can train students to spot um
online fiction from online fact and can
get better at recognizing conspiracy
theories and it's it like even listen to
him like this is so dystopian where is
your who is your speech writer this is
crazy their mask off you guys might have
a new uh movie in the works here just
Kathy Hook's life all right kth Swiss
says you sir went to the wrong cheese
store don't be besmirching Wisconsin's
good name here here yeah Wisconsin is
the land of cheese man like they they
they they have the the cheese hats yeah
you got good stuff going we were driving
through and there was a sign that's like
you can buy cheese here and we just
pulled off in this farm and they just
had tons of like it was amazing amazing
uhhuh I stopped at a maple farm a couple
weeks ago was awesome we got Maple
everything it's like an eighth
generation Maple Farm oh crazy like
going back to the late 1600s or
something cuz appar they were saying
that back in the day Maple was how you
got sugar yeah it it was it was that was
what you used yeah so they would make
maple sugar by drying it out and and
then pulverizing it and then brown sugar
and uh yeah maple sugar process white
sugar was very expensive back then comes
from beets right crazy crazy all right
everybody if you haven't talk ready
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends we got a very very
special Thanksgiving members only show
coming up for you in just a few minutes
you don't want to miss it you got to go
to
timcast.net angel.com thees shift yep to
pick up tickets for the movie it's
already it's already selling out all
over I saw you buy them right in the
middle the show yeah we got a bunch we
got some for the crew so it's perfect
Friday so we're going to go we're g to
go watch for sure thank you it's it like
it's not going to disappoint but this is
a very different movie meaning you've
never seen anything like it right on
very cool hi I'm hler rmo I'm a writer
for scanner or SC CNR uh.com I'm really
excited to be there and I'm really uh
proud of the timcast news crew for
converting over uh it's been it's been a
a trial but very fun so uh you can see
all the work from me from Chris burtman
from the rest of our Journal journalists
over there um yeah same great stuff
probably even more coming you should
follow at timcast news on the social
medias those those handels are remaining
the same and yeah I'm sure there'll be
more updates along the way but I'm
really grateful for you guys for
checking it out uh if you want to follow
me personally I'm on Instagram at Hannah
clairy I'm on X at uh HD rmo I can never
remember what my handles are and okay
yeah Happy Thanksgiving guys it's like
you're playing with blocks and looking
for the right shape piece every time not
every time and my name is so long to
have a double first name I always forget
what it is anyways I'm lucky that I
branded at Ian Crossland all across the
internet so search find me and follow me
there uh I put out some badass
interviews I interviewed Josie the
redheaded libertarian today at 1:00 in
the afternoon on YouTube X Rumble minds
and Facebook it was multistream but
follow me subscribe check it out man and
I'll I'll see you guys soon awesome to
see you guys I want to tell that Ona and
much gratitude to you guys for helping
us get sound of Freedom out there oh hey
man it is what it is movie we want we
want to win a culture War so that means
we have to maximize anybody who's who's
winning I mean what you guys are doing
we're huge fans of uh Angel Studios
Public Square all that stuff has to
happen this is the resonation and
amplification chamber welcome aboard one
piece of it welcome into it yes all
right a surge uh yeah yeah I'm surge.com
uh I don't have much to say other than
if you want to argue with me please find
me on Twix surge.com um I will not be on
Discord for the mo near future I suppose
uh that said let's go to the after show
Tim we'll see you all over at
timcast.net